you know how like when you've read manga
you can like pick pick like the pace
you're reading at right yeah so everyone
has a different pace right then which
reminds me yeah speaking of pacing
and poop pooping
what made you just bring this up oh
because i heard poop and that hurt
i did not say food
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste i'm your host for today
guards joining me today again are the
boys and who is this sitting next to me
do you want to introduce yourself to the
world who are you it's me dodis
what is this
i've been abusing this a lot every time
like someone wants something from me i'm
like
what does this mean what they're using
it means
i don't know it's not like one stop in
like hawaii or something yeah yeah yeah
exactly
actually yeah
i just like that i like it because i
don't have to speak i just
what do you mute
well since uh
moving to japan i've been doing this
lately like
it's like yes i understand is that just
like nod to other people like yeah no no
matter what like if i'm passing by
somebody they see me i'm like
[Laughter]
it's automatically
why so just you just do that to everyone
everyone you pass on the street you know
only if like they i don't know they like
make eye contact there's a narrow
hallway or they make eye contact i'll be
like
it's just automatic i don't know
actually it was crazy i saw the um
i saw this lady on the phone yeah yeah
she's talking on her cell phone like
this
like this
and she she was going
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i was like
that's the craziest thing i've ever seen
in my life
like why are you why are you cradling
like a baby
yeah yeah she's bowing on the phone like
constantly i've seen i've seen [ __ ]
salaryman do like full like 90 degree
like yeah full-on bowing on the phone
yeah why i don't honest honestly
honestly like i bow by like habit as
well sometimes just yeah yeah like when
when i like end the conversation i just
like have to bow like it's just like a
knee joke reaction yeah it is it is
right i have to do this yeah yeah yeah
even if i'm like on the phone like yeah
hey
yeah
impossible for you to say hi on the
phone without like moving your neck yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can't just go hi
hi yeah like
vayne popping
[Music]
i guess the reason why you're impressed
by bowing is because you just moved here
but also i mean i mean i mean
audience who do not know who you are do
you want to explain what you do on
youtube who you are yeah i'm a i'm a
loser that animates my life i guess and
then when i'm bored of animating my life
i do
fun random stuff that you know and then
like
like what yeah like what's the random
stuff you do
um
game
no
yes it is yes it is what do you mean
well i make like little so
most time like a story time animator but
yeah i don't really yeah you got to keep
the mic pretty close to you oh hello
yeah
you gotta like you gotta
yeah so you make
other things
uh yeah i mostly make just animations
basically and then
um
[Laughter]
and you're a member of geeksplus now
aren't you i am yeah yeah yeah how does
it feel to be in japan because you just
moved here like
three weeks ago i forgot not even a
month a month ago right
three weeks ago or something i can't
remember the time goes fly by fast
because like i'm just building furniture
constantly
that's how it always is yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then we're going to like
the japanese bank and then they try to
give me a bank account and i'm just like
sitting here and then there's like two
japanese ladies it's like translating
yeah
they're like going back and forth and
then it literally i got there at like 8
a.m yeah and then went all the way
to like i think we got out like 7 00 p.m
jesus the bank plus the phone the phone
too oh yeah
literally took like i don't know like an
entire day entire day yeah
this is and i felt useless too because i
can't speak the language yet right yeah
yeah
he was like sitting there and it just
like it's just like translating and then
yeah i was uh applying for a visa to
come here oh it was a it was a it was
death
when did you start when did you start
because i think i i basically was like
you know i'd been teasing them all about
how fun japan is and they'd be like oh
because originally i hate this guy he
would post like pictures of food and
stuff and i'm like i hate this [ __ ]
i i've i played league with emily and
iris a lot and we obviously do our
videos together and uh
you know originally you're going to come
to japan in april 2020. for a vacation
given the back story yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i like the law so you're going to
come in 2020 with emily to come just
hang out and visit yeah and obviously as
we all know what happens
and then we're like don't worry you'll
it'll it'll open up soon it'll open up
soon yeah it'll open up it never opened
up yeah so it's like what 2021 like
mid-2021 and i was like
i mean just
are you interested in like coming here
no actually no i think two years ago you
said i uh do you want to move there you
asked me and i was like right i think i
asked emily i was like well i feel like
we should test japan to see if we like
it first yeah yeah we're gonna visit
yeah cause i've heard that you've never
left the states before moving here to
japan i oh yeah yeah i've only been to
canada and florida so i live in maine
well that's two different countries
a different country and florida oh it's
also a different country
so japan japan was like a very big jump
there
yeah yeah so well my mom's cambodian
yeah yeah yeah like half chinese or
whatever
yeah uh but she never brought me to
cambodia because he's always like afraid
of like dangers like yeah over there so
i'm like
well
i guess i never got the visit ever yeah
yeah like literally ever close now
though
yeah yeah exactly
now yeah i i hope it's more safe yeah so
jesus you'd like just like you
like flew the coop then because like you
went from not basically going out of
north america to [ __ ] moving to japan
just just just like that
not even visiting you are now just
living here okay well first of all the
boys were closed forever and ever and
ever and ever and ever waiting literally
like a year or whatever
long i was dying in my basement i was
rotting
there's nothing to do there i was bored
as hell in my mom's basement my mom did
my laundry
she cooked for me
that's an important point
i was just like i was just chilling too
hard yeah the fact that like i didn't
want to do anything i was just right
right
yeah i was just like
playing video games i'm going to be
honest yeah
i was just rotting away yeah and you
know finally the borders open up and
then oh yeah i also gained i gained like
50 pounds and then i lost
20 pounds right then i regained 20
pounds and then i lost 20 30 pounds or
something so i've been yoyoing i just
sounds like i don't know in general
no it was just it was just
cold that just sounds like
metabolism you know like yeah i don't
know just like gaining a few pounds and
you're just like [ __ ] i need to go on a
diet you'd like diet good for a month
you're like yes i've lost those pounds i
can keep going you don't keep going and
then you gain the pounds back you're
like [ __ ] i should die again and then
you start dieting and it's like it's
like a yo-yo between like the same like
10 pounds or whatever you just never win
exactly it's very sad because um
uh
i think before
2020 happened you know the whole culvert
thing happened you know i was gonna
visit japan yeah and i was like at my
peak i was like pretty skinny like i was
at the you know i was comfortable in my
own body i was like i'm gonna put myself
out there and then uh covered hit and i
was like oh and then i
i just became a basement dweller again
it was very
so you decided just be just to like
[ __ ] get out and just like do
something just to get a change basically
so i've been i've been yearning to like
uh
just like i went to i lived i used to
live in new york during college
art college right um and that was like
essentially like throwing myself out
there right into the wild right and i
miss that feeling of like just being
thrown into a wild
yeah trying to figure stuff out
not even like i just like the fact that
if you it's like what is this thing and
it's like it peaks it like piques your
brain you're like wait this is this is
something different and yeah yeah in
maine or or just like united states like
any state you go to is not really that
much different yeah except florida
except florida and then you get shot
that's why i like about japan like yeah
like the whole like you have an umbrella
and you put it in the the slot thing and
yeah
and it takes off oh you lock the
umbrella
and i was like this is the umbrella yeah
yeah
i was like this is crazy
and also the the workers in america
every time you go to like let's say
7-eleven yeah first of all you got like
a bunch of druggy guys over there like
right what do you call them homeless
people or something
i mean i guess i don't know
i don't know what the politically
correct term for that is but i'm pretty
sure
especially in new york like every time i
leave at like
3 a.m in the morning right i'll always
get pursued
by by uh yeah that sounds like a
panhandler yeah yeah and then they'll
follow you into the store
and then
and then they you know i'm like well i
would give you money but if i gave you
money that means i would have to give
one dollar
like no i'd have to give like 50 bucks
every day because you literally get
begged right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
i'm like
i don't know it's just is this nonstop
right right right anyway so the uh the
gas station starts yeah
go back to japan
right also by the way the workers in
7-eleven or wherever they are they look
like they don't want to be there they
just want to
they they look sad well in america or
japan in america okay
yeah i mean it's pretty chill because
you're just like you going i don't think
you're paid enough to like also also
then have to pretend to be happy about
it like i mean to be fair it's kind of
the same way in japan as well
they pretend to be yeah
no it's so different yeah actually i
wasn't so much that chill though yeah
yeah
yeah some sometimes
yeah yeah sometimes well that was one
time actually like i think this happened
like three when i just came to japan i
went to 7-eleven i went to get like a
beer like strong zero or whatever and
then it wasn't scanning the guy like ran
you like ran because it wasn't skinny
you ran through the fridge and then he
ran back like
come here
and i was like oh you don't need to do
that like
he's like he's like bowing and stuff
like that yeah this is so sad like like
i like the service you're giving me yeah
i feel bad that you have to like feel
like you have to act this way yeah
that's the thing though right like the
japan's like standard for customer
service is so insanely high that there
is probably like some [ __ ] japanese
guy or girl out there who would complain
being like come on hurry up yeah yeah
you know it makes me sad like a little
bit but at the same time i get good
service yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
sometimes the service is so good that
it's like imposing i'm just like you
don't get like you don't need i don't
need the service to be this good bro you
can chill you know sometimes i do it so
good that like next time you go to like
the same place like when you go to
ryokan right yeah sometimes when they
like when you get there they welcome you
like you're a king dude yeah that's what
i'm saying they come and they take your
bags they're like looking after you and
then other times you'll go to another
royal can you be like you'll be like i
hope they do it but i won't expect it
and then you get disappointed when
they're like what are you on
yeah when you do when you find that one
guy that like doesn't care you're just
like what is this like yeah
yeah yeah yeah it like completely like
warps your like perspective about it
even though like you go anywhere else in
america and it's like it's just normal
yeah
yeah it's just like it's it's like
warped my perception of
you know what is what i find is good
service and what even like what even
stands out to me because i remember like
i was like because i was in england last
week i remember just like going to a
normal restaurant you know
and uh it was such a small thing because
i was so used to just like the japanese
service being like as polite and as you
know soft as they can so i remember it
was just like it was i went to a
restaurant and then i asked for the bill
right and it was just such a small thing
uh they slammed it down on the table and
said uh it's a
they slammed down the team and said 50
pounds
i was just like oh that's that that was
a bit aggressive like you know what i
mean it was it was like because like
it's it it surprised me because i was so
used to like you know japanese japanese
service just like bringing it to you it
would be like 50 pounds
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly right
exactly right i didn't even get a please
you know or something or you know well
thank you
50 pounds
it's quite odd even for the uk to be
fair really really i don't know because
i've i've it's been so long since i've
been to the uk that i'm just like am i
an [ __ ] for thinking that was a bit
aggressive they don't say the price out
loud right am i crazy oh they're kind of
just like here's the let me just give it
to you right yeah well it's interesting
they bring the bill to you in the uk but
in japan i noticed you always had to go
up to there well so it depends on the
restaurant differently
i haven't been to a single one where
they gave you the bill yeah for some
reason sometimes you have to pay at the
table so they bring you the bill
normally the fancier it is or the more
european it's trying to be you pay the
debt yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah then if
it's if it's just like what if it's like
a japanese i'm waiting for that moment
bro
yeah hasn't happened yet i'll i'll take
you too yeah yeah yeah i know all places
i know a place
best italian food in india yeah like
normally if it's uh if it's japanese
food then you'll pay it like the till
but if you go to like a more westernized
place than it is they try to like i
guess embrace foreign culture it's fine
some of the restaurants will actually
have like a thing that says pay at the
table yeah obviously well if they want
to embrace foreign culture they should
do tips i'm just kidding
i wish they didn't
american tips i don't want twenty
percent of the [ __ ] bill yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] phone we don't eat out as
much i don't blame i noticed the the
grocery store if you live in the city
the grocery store is like more expensive
than eating out which is like yeah japan
is like one of the rare countries where
eating out is actually cheaper yeah it's
so weird last time you said that we got
some people who are like oh you said
that's not true at all you can you well
if you live in a city i guess yeah
certain things are cheaper certain
things are more expensive like obviously
if you go to you know size here and get
a pasta you get like this much like 300
yen then yeah you should make your own
pasta but that's like pasta like if you
want a ramen you can't make your own
ramen for at home yeah it's going to be
like so many ingredients the melons
like three hundred dollars why
have you have you tried one of them like
this and it's three hundred what because
some guy like rubs it for hours he's
just like what do you mean haven't you
tried one of them
no no no no no i'm just i'm just asking
have you tried it no no no um it's not
nothing it's it's not worth it it's not
worth it no because i actually saw like
i actually saw a documentary on this on
like why the melons in japan are so
expensive
yeah they do it's like a very like
japanese culture they wear so like they
only pick the cream of the crop every
melon is like grated and like it's
perfect it's not just like the taste
it's like a look it's the look it's like
the like the crinkling on the side as
well that gets great as well for like
look an aesthetic and i'm just like i do
not give a [ __ ]
i'm just like is it just kind of sweet
okay that's cool it's because in japan
giving fruit is like the utmost like it
yeah it's a flex for like gift giving
that's like a lobsters they used to be
like a slavery food right like peasant
food yeah yeah now they're like yeah a
delicacy i don't know fruit is the same
way
[Laughter]
but yeah like because in japan it's like
gift giving such a huge thing and like
giving fruit to someone is like oh [ __ ]
you really care for me yeah so that's
why they make it expensive to come it
won't work on us right well it won't
work on us yeah we're just like just
give me a [ __ ] granny smith i'll be
good you know yeah go to the grocery
store buy me a cheaper grape yeah
exactly like you spend how much on this
watermelon yeah yeah cause cause like i
i've noticed that about i guess like the
japanese artisan culture which i guess
i'm gonna call it which is like one
thing i can say about
japan is that if you're a craft
craftsman you put like your [ __ ]
heart and soul into whatever you're
making right i mean that's why japan has
like such a high standard for so many
things right and you know you you know
you see this with for example with you
know like japanese tools like japanese
knives for example you see like
documentaries about you know people who
have like inherited their [ __ ] grand
great great grandfather's like [ __ ]
blacksmith or something yeah generation
six yeah yeah every single one of those
documentaries is the same yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then they'll be like oh what
makes what makes your uh salt so special
and then they'll go on about the family
recipe and yeah how they love it yeah it
almost always starts with this isn't
just any knife
yeah yeah i'm crying from the rocky
mountains
this has been passed down through the
knowledge of like [ __ ] five different
generations great grandfather yeah yeah
yeah yeah just made nine and then it's
like it's like the same way with the
melons for example where you look at the
melon farms and it's like you know
yeah and like i you know i respect the
fact they have like such pride with
their work and their craft but there's a
point when i'm just gonna like be like
it's just a melon you know
i'm sorry i'm sorry it is it's really
cool and like i have like so much
respect for people who do that kind of
stuff but like i'm not always gonna buy
into it yeah yeah
there are some things where i'm just
like you know there are some tools i'm
just like yes this definitely does need
the care and attention and the knowledge
of like years of work and sometimes i'm
just like i mean it's slightly sweeter
you know it's a slightly sweet
strawberry is it worth us that much i
don't oh i don't know i don't know it
just doesn't work in other countries
yeah it doesn't it reminds me of like
maylene when she's like these eggs are
like eight dollars eight dollars
like eight dollar eggs and it's like
tastes like rich and stuff i say i'm
like tastes like an egg
no i am i am exactly the same i'm team
died
yeah yeah it's a load of [ __ ] it's like
i'm sorry if the melons [ __ ] ready to
eat i don't need like tanaka center
massage yeah yeah i'll just eat it oh
yeah i'll just i'll eat it like i don't
i don't i don't know to me it's just
like i don't know this obsessive nature
of like
the fruit and things have to be perfect
and it's like in the uk as well we used
to like i think uh you'd throw away like
carrots or stuff that weren't like the
right shape right yeah you wouldn't buy
them yeah just [ __ ] give it to them
like i wouldn't mind so much if there at
least was like a cheapo option you know
because like yeah you know because if it
feels like you know i'm fine if i want
to like you know treat myself and i know
like i'm going to buy a fruit that is
like 100 of the time [ __ ] a grade you
know like you know sometimes like you
buy a pack of strawberries in the uk and
it's like it's like strawberry gacha
sometimes it's like a little bit sour
sometimes you get that perfectly sweet
one but you know it's like in japan
every strawberry you buy is like that
sweet like that sweet one every single
time
but i do want to the option to just be
like just give me a [ __ ] cheap
give me the [ __ ] pack that i just want
to like stuff myself literally like pay
to win it it is
it's like you are paying so that you
guarantee every strawberry is going to
be an ssl yeah yeah oh my [ __ ] god
it's just like why did they put like
fruit behind a pay wall
all the
foods to like
put behind the paywall yeah like the
other thing i wouldn't mind either is
like you know say for example if it's
like knives right or like tools or
something that makes sense that shit's
gonna last you for a long time right
because like there's quality to it yeah
i can finish a packet of strawberries in
like five minutes you know so it's like
oh cool so the thing i just spent five
minutes on that cost 200 yeah yeah yeah
like a parity documentary of like a
flaming hot cheeto like a premium
version being made this isn't just any
flavor like hand dust it
like spread the dust on this is made by
chester cheetah himself
they like hand fry every single cheeto
before like dusting it with like [ __ ]
and then massage
like it's like infused with like fairy
dust or some [ __ ] like that
but yeah like i suppose unlike us you
moved here post covered right so i'm
curious what the procedure for you was
like oh yeah i forgot we uh talked about
yeah
we went on a tangent we do that a lot
here on trash taste yeah okay yeah so so
take us through the take us through the
process oh yeah it was it was a first oh
voice quick
because you you told me it was like it
was a painful process and i was like hey
it can't be that bad and then like you
know it's fine we're just chilling
waiting for the board to open but then
when it actually opened it was it was
such a pain it was like you signed
one paper yeah the same information yeah
and then you have to do that 20 more
times yeah yeah and then you have to
like i had to drive to the borough which
is only in boston drive all the way
there the embassy the embassy and then
the lady was like who's this gaijin
trying to get into her country like she
treated me like trash i was like yeah
fair enough like i understand
[Laughter]
i understand
and then she's like come back a week
drive back and then drive it again yeah
get that thing it's very frustrating to
go to the embassies especially the far
away yeah when they're far away you
don't know like how they operate
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then that
whole deal happened and then yet luckily
i had the passport already but then one
of the annoying parts the kovid they
call it mysos it's like an app where you
have to get into oh yeah yeah oh yeah
what's super troll about this is that
when i got to the airport when i landed
in japan the app stopped working and
then all these people who like couldn't
communicate with me were like
why is your phone not working and i was
like it's not just me like all these
other people's like apps aren't working
yeah so the app is really buggy yeah
yeah so then they like sent me to a
computer to put the same information i
did like 37 times yeah try to do it
again
and then
yeah so to explain uh this is this is
the app i just have it as well because i
just came to japan
did i call you uh they don't call me
because i don't need to quarantine
because that was really i'm boosted they
like called me you're boosted
i'm boosted baby
yeah they called me they and they
checked on me like every day
yeah they caught me on stream and i i
last time when we needed to quarantine
they call you every day but i believe
like now you just have to download it
just to register that you are coming
into the country
if it works i mean like i felt like i i
i go like because i've done this before
and i did it through like hard mode
right when i came in we would like
literally treated like cattle like they
would give us they would like we come in
and they like tag us and brand us and be
like those yeah those are the people
coming in and we
we literally spent four hours in the
airports and like how long did you spend
in the airports very quick well not
quite quick because you know the whole
like yeah maybe three hours three that's
pretty good you're getting the visa yeah
if you were getting there yeah and you
were getting the visa as well
uh can i talk [ __ ] about delta is that
one yeah yeah you could talk [ __ ] about
it we're not sponsored
so that's literally our partner
actually yeah [ __ ] delta dude i've i've
i've run with them three times they
[ __ ] me over all three times anyways
they delayed my [ __ ]
um
flight my flight by yeah
and what the thing is that you needed
the covet test oh oh yeah yeah well you
get results in two days yeah so i had to
time it perfectly yeah and then when i
did time perfectly delta canceled my
japan trip they put they made me get
stuck in detroit i'm like literally just
stuck in detroit all night yeah and then
when i got to the airport they were like
hey uh your covet test is late by a day
and then i had a show like taking it
like yo they delayed me by a whole day
and they had to bring the manager and
then the manager had to bring the other
manager
and then the manager managers had to
bring the other manager and he came over
and he's like okay you're good
that's the most japanese story i've ever
heard in my life
and i'm like just get me in the goddamn
country already like i'm tired i'm
sweaty yeah uh yeah see i i think i
think i must have taken like the most
optimized path you could possibly get to
take in the country because i was only
at the airport for like an hour and a
half but like i i prepared my covet
tests i made sure like it was dated and
timed and made sure to print out all my
tickets
yeah did you did you pre-register as
well i did you did i did and it didn't
work it wasn't working and
and i even screenshotted the barcode oh
yeah but so was it gonna take was the
app green
um
no because only one of them was wasn't
accepting my vaccine yeah yeah yeah yeah
so you need to make sure you get like
the right kind of vaccine card and then
if you get the right kind of vaccine
card uh the app will turn green and like
if they see a green app they're just
like let this man through let this man
through he's not a green card he's not
like the rest he's done the paperwork
he's done the paperwork get him through
yeah literally i think i skipped like
like an hour and a half to two hours
just because i was able to get the green
app good job
i've done the speed run guys i've done
the speed run
yeah because i i knew how anal like
japan were with documents so i was just
like i need to make sure every document
is
on par with their exact specifications
when you do something in the uk and i
assume the us sometimes you read some
stuff guidelines you're like i'm sure
that's not that important right like in
japan if it's written there they're
gonna check yeah yeah yeah they will
check
sure japan is the only country where
like you actually have to read the fine
print yeah yeah because they do
everything the fine princess i i uh i
did i went above and beyond and i still
got like kind of cute that's japan for
you that is japan that's japan so so
yeah
you still took three hours just because
you had to like re-sign everything and
really actually the day before that when
i transferred it to uh
detroit yeah they kept they kept being
like oh we're gonna get another pilot
one hour later oh the pilot's coming one
hour later three hours later and then
they go oh cancelled and then like
here's your hotel go to hotel waste the
whole last day go the next day and then
you know finally load then i got the
airport three hours and then mainly
picked me up and i was like and then i
met you guys at the uh that
the restaurant
yeah pretty mid yeah
this episode is sponsored by honey the
easy way to save when shopping on your
iphone or computer guys you know we all
shop online of course of course we do
where else do we shop in real life now
how often do you feel that that promo
code just taunts you at the checkout
every time well thanks to honey manually
searching for coupons codes are a thing
of the past really honey's the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart
imagine it you're shopping on one of
your favorite sites okay you get to the
checkout the honey button appears and
all you have to do is click apply coupon
wait a few seconds is how he searches
through coupons it can find for that
site if honey finds a working coupon
you'll watch the prices drop
i recently bought some nice dress shirts
gentlemen i know i know fancy because
we're going to the uk and i managed to
save 15 bucks on a 100 order thanks to
honey 15 bucks i know ladies and
gentlemen if you haven't already used
honey you could be straight up missing
out on savings and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
the boys as well so you can get honey
for free at jointhoney.com trashtaste
that's join honey.com
trash taste back to the episode i i
gotta say since uh dinus and emily came
like like after geeksplus has already
obviously been formed for a while oh
they got the [ __ ] vip treatment
coming into japan they got picked up
right at the airport by maylin and geeks
plus staff you know like i believe emily
got the same treatment where me and
connor we were just left to like
find a way to like our house and joey
yeah find joey
can you come help me i've got so many
bags and then he helped me out in like
nippori yeah yeah
and like joey was the one who took care
of it and i remember that because i
remember i was trying to do the same
thing to connor because we were like me
and sydney were going to stay around
connor's house right and like connor was
kind of just like yeah joey helped me
with his bags and everything like that
so have i told her on the podcast yeah
okay about me not helping you guys yes i
didn't know you had that many bags i
would have helped if i know
the most [ __ ] up thing i hadn't even
joined geeks bosses yeah i was literally
just doing it on my own yeah meanwhile
elaine's just [ __ ] sitting back
eating her eight dollar eggs
yeah
yeah back then geeks plus was just
mailing and now geeks plus is an entire
team so of course
i'm surprised they put him up in a hotel
yeah yeah we were we were the beta chest
basically uh don't tell joey yeah
i stayed in hotel connor
slept on his floor you know that was uh
very luxurious
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry
so once you got into the country
everything was good you reckon
well
i mean we always needed a translator we
like really like translated like yeah
yeah like everything literally yeah yeah
that was joey's job at the beginning
yeah i wasn't even paid for it yeah
because you guys are like already
established so you you guys go oh you
want to go out to here yeah yeah okay
and then you do all the speaking and i'm
just like
[Laughter]
yeah and then uh well we did our first
lesson like
two weeks ago but then golden week hit
yeah yeah just like oh you're going to
japanese lessons yeah yeah oh nice for
sure for sure i i i feel so useless man
i really doesn't make you feel like a
like an infant i just can't do anything
yeah i feel so i never felt so useless
in my life but that's why i like about
it it's like um you like that no no i i
like it
i don't want to do anything let everyone
else do everything
that's cool though because like i don't
know many people who have like
never left their country who are
suddenly just like yeah you know what
i'm just gonna
live well
i've never been to you know if you live
in your mom's basement basement long
enough you just you just
you want to
there in seoul for a very long time
right right right right right i mean but
like rent is like insane in the u.s
right getting a place to rent it's my
mom's basement so yeah it's like if you
wanted to leave your mom's basement like
the rent is really high
it depends on what state you're running
depends where you are
i don't know what it's like in maine but
i guess like new york man it's getting
cheaper i'm not more expensive because
the hipsters are moving in right it's
kind of like williamsburg they made it
super expensive i mean i know like new
york is like [ __ ] great
actually i when i went to brooklyn i
used to be uh
i used to be cheap and and ghetto and i
came back like you know a couple years
after college and it like completely you
know it's like super fast fancy i was
like where's my ghetto brooklyn that i
missed i missed the ghettoness where is
it
yeah i've heard it's become like the art
district of new york right like it's
like like a lot of hipsters like living
in brooklyn i literally think it's it's
the art colleges yeah
you try to pay rent once for like within
your sock or something
what oh
oh yeah yeah i was just okay i'll tell
you a story
so like i was just thinking
it's 2 a.m in the morning yeah and i'm
like well
i got i got to pay rent to my roommate
real like yeah quick
so i had to the only way to do is a cash
18 in new york right all right yeah in
new york my brooklyn apartment yeah
right right and the deli is only like
five minute walk so i'm like okay i'll
just go to the deli get the 500
and then but i'm so stupid because in my
head i'm like well it's 2 a.m in the
morning
and
what if i get mugged right i should hide
it in a really good spot
and i hid it in my shoe
i hid in my shoe and while i was walking
back
the money flew out my shoe
then i didn't know and i got back to my
apartment i was like where's my money so
then i went outside like in the dark
like looking like this
and then like a bunch of like you know
people came up to me and he's like yeah
yo what you what are you looking for and
i'm like um
have you guys seen any like money like
500 around like
and they're like nah man
and i knew they were acting i knew i i
think they picked it up yeah yeah yeah
yeah man
dude
that was crazy what and i was like okay
i i know you guys have it i didn't say
that loudly like
this is a gg i'm going to call my dad
and be like yeah i lost a 500 sorry
i felt bad why did you shoot like you
didn't put it like deep into yours like
are you like letting it hang out yeah
i put it as deep as i don't know
you have a hole in your shoe maybe it's
just kind of like no i just maybe
physics or something i don't know man
i don't know man
all the mugging was just that good
dude i unlocked myself technically
oh my god that is the most like i live
in new york story i've ever had yeah
yeah
well my my favorite time in new york is
like going out like 2 a.m in the morning
because then you get like the crackheads
[Music]
why is that a good thing why is that a
good thing
i don't know it's kind of uh it's a vibe
[Laughter]
but it's because i'm a dude so yeah i'm
technically always safe but if you're
like a girl
you're gonna it's real bad i don't know
man i've been to new york and i never
felt safe even like during the day yeah
no
actually being in japan i always feel
safe now yeah right this is crazy no
guns no stabbing
you gotta learn how to how to talk to
them so what i do is when you go up and
talk to them no no if they approach you
oh
you got to be like homie to them so like
what i do is i like to say man so i'm
like so they go
this is a pro strategy okay they
approach you they're like give me two
dollars hey can i have two dollars and
you go no sorry man and then you gotta
add the man in there so so if i just say
so if i just say no so
no sorry they're gonna be they're gonna
be like no sorry yeah they're offended
you know i'm
you know native to america but i don't
think that's gonna like stop anything if
someone wants no it does you'll be
surprised
[Music]
manchester united
wait what dude the dude asking so like
by saying man what does that do like why
does that work
oh it's just it's just like it's almost
like yeah it's like word disarming right
right right i don't know if this is
[Music]
yeah so if you just say no sorry that's
like kind of rude say no sorry man or in
like in that tone no sorry man
i cannot provide you with the cash that
you require right now
[Laughter]
if you can make them laugh they let you
go you know
i mean look like i believe
this is one simple trick there's a part
of me that believes you but like not in
saying that i'm not going to try it yeah
i mean i haven't been mugged yet so
yeah well
i mean i don't think i'll be mugged here
right i mean i i i already unlocked yeah
yeah yeah yeah unless it's an umbrella
in which case that's just like free
range oh yeah yeah someone stole emily's
umbrella yeah do you
be like that yeah people don't steal
here unless it's umbrellas yeah because
it's it's not your umbrella it's the
community on brotherhood yeah
like people are trying to make you join
cults really yeah it happens
it hasn't happened to me yet that's good
it will happen do i have to go to like
the countryside no you don't know don't
follow them no you're following them no
you just have to be like sorry man sorry
right sorry
i don't want to join your card
i don't want to go pray yeah
i don't think it'll work here they don't
understand english that much
they're the cults too oh they do
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you want to pray you say no and then
i'll show you a picture of mount fuji
yeah and that's that should be your sign
yeah it's always mount for you always i
always question like what exactly do you
do with this cult though like they just
they they just like get money from you
yeah normally they make you kind of make
you do you live with them and then it's
usually i mean it's usually like it
starts off with is this brainwashing
yeah it starts off with a scam which
then eventually leads on to some like
more yeah i don't say devious licks but
you know
it gets a little you know
serious episode of golden time right
there's like a cult thing going on is
that yeah yeah japan and weirdly has a
lot of cults yeah yeah yeah they're
really really really like active yeah
there's a lot of really big ones as well
yeah it's because there's no like one
organized religion like a lot of
countries so it's kind of just like
free-for-all basically i'm guessing
because of the aging population as well
it's very easy to use i can't see it
i was like i was fine and then conor
like randomly like well i was hanging
out with him this dude just randomly
dropped yeah there's like a lot of old
people more old people than young people
i was like no there's not they're not
like the next week i've been walking
around i'm like
oh my god they're everywhere
everywhere
if you go to a supermarket it's probably
like 80 yeah elderly people it's
interesting i was like whoa i i was i
was just like i saw a news article just
the other day i mean this is outdated by
the time being but like do you know what
percentage of the population is below 15
in japan wait wait would you say
what what what population like what
percentage of the japanese population is
below 15 years old
what do you think
20
10 percent
that's how like that's how many like old
people there are or older people there
are less young people less younger this
is what happens when everyone plays
gotcha
i agree with that
the sex shop is all i needed to see
so how does like new york as a big city
compared to tokyo always living there
it's like
tokyo is amazing yeah i actually i love
it here
it's literally new york
but clean
yeah
you're welcome
well new york has the grid system which
is like it gets boring because you just
what straight lines right yeah yeah
japan has just like get straight lines
and then
yeah like lots of little like that's
that's it that's all you know i mean no
food differences in a restaurant oh oh
my god dude
they're looking at it in the eyes of
like an architect
i'm like straight lines
japan everyone
i like i like i like lost like 20 pounds
before getting here yeah obviously not
my goal right yeah
which i hate but anyways i'm trying to
[ __ ] lose weight here in japan
impossible there's like every you go
down one street food food food food go
next one food food food food yeah food
food food snack snack snack snack it's
impossible and it's all carbs and i'm
just like i can't i can't like control
myself i'm like and then you have a beer
and then you have a beer and then you
have a beer which is cheap because in if
you want to buy a beer normally if you
go to the bar you have to tip the
bartender yeah yeah yeah
and then the beer costs like eight
dollars so it's like nine dollar a beer
it's like over here it's like what like
three bucks yeah no tips yeah
yeah i've been to some izakayas where
it's 50 yen a beer oh okay wow wow
yeah yeah that's right so that's why i
noticed they have like low carb beer too
which is i shot the green label i showed
him the the green stuff why would you do
that why would you do that it's good
because he was he was constantly
complaining about carbs and stuff and i
was like
i was like daddy says [ __ ] taste he'll
probably like this beer
i like why drinks pretty good
it's literally like water it doesn't
taste like beer
yeah yeah like water
i'm not i'm not a disenforcer here i'm
not a water audacity
but it's like it's like do you like bud
light
it's water a can is like 100 calories
and like no carbs yeah it's pretty you
know if you're on a diet it's pretty
friendly well the thing in america right
now
in america right now is very popular
it's the um hard seltzer yeah what's
that i thought it was
a warning
seltzer walls it's literally also water
but like they put alcohol in it or salsa
water
like just isn't it carbonated water
carbonated water
puts a little bit of flavoring in it
okay so they've removed the fondant
they've removed the fun from white claw
which already wasn't fun originally it
depends on which salsa you want but yeah
white claw is the most popular one okay
okay okay
but they put alcohol in it they do
like five to six eight percent or
something oh so it's like a strong zero
basically
no no it's it's it's it's basically just
yeah alcohol water or something right
it's it's hand sanitizer
what lengths have we gone to like the
normal
sparkling normally they call sparkling
when it's like it has flavor enhanced
does it i don't think yeah like
aspartame or whatever it's called what's
the other one there's a bunch of other
brands like
perrier or whatever area that's that's
sparkling water
exactly but that's what sparkling water
is that's what's the difference between
salsa well then well seltzer sorry
seltzer water but it says sparkling i'm
talking on my own
tell me what your sauce is
[ __ ] up i feel like i feel like salsa
water is like unflavored though and then
like sparkling's like here's a cherry
flavor
uh yeah yeah i guess so do you find that
japan is giving you any inspiration for
the video yeah yeah yes yeah super
motivation
yeah because when i made you know when i
did youtube as a job yeah in
the united states or maine or whatever
my mom's basement basically yeah yeah i
didn't really have like any reason to
make money i was just like when i did
make money i was like
all right but like i never
i never had a use for it
because i don't i didn't pay for my food
my mom was like yeah yeah but then like
my mom was like
you should move out but she's also very
sad about it too yeah yeah yeah i'm like
oh man i'm like conflicted but then i'm
like
i gotta move out like i have to like
mentally yeah yeah i was rotting down
there yeah yeah yeah um especially when
i think i wanted to move out when before
covert hit and then hit and i was like
yeah well i just
basement again all right right right i
eat domino's pizza and did you always
plan to move to japan or was it just
like the opportunity came and you're
like all right this is it this is what
i've been waiting for i'll take anything
i mean
if the opportunity arrives yeah
okay yeah i mean yeah yeah you got an
opportunity that like a lot of people
would kill for yeah yeah i mean like uh
i'm i'm a weeb
right
we know yeah yeah yeah this is really
weird going to the cobini and like
seeing like detective conan and i'm like
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll go on the train
and i'll see like gotcha advertisements
or like yeah yeah nice anime art and i'm
like this is crazy i was like
it's pretty wild
i'm so sad because like i missed out on
the like because i wasn't in tokyo when
you like were here yeah we gotta hang
out yeah yeah yeah of course but like i
i missed out on like the initial like
yeah yeah yeah japan like saga that
happened yeah well i'm still like every
time i go to a convenience store i'm
still like what is this what is that
it's like there's so many things you
know yeah
because i love seeing reactions to like
people who come to japan for the first
time yeah yeah
like everything right because i remember
my first reaction like seeing a [ __ ]
combini and just like yeah beanie's like
the funnest one
yeah
it is it is i've gone to the conbini
i've seen japan
like [ __ ] akihabara it's all about the
combinations man
japan you should go to like food then at
the conbini what are you eating i'm like
i like 7 11 the best yeah what are you
eating though oh i'm not like everything
all no not everything just whatever
i'm i'm trying to stay healthy right so
yeah yeah have you had the cup ramen yet
no it's pretty good
let's that's right
did you not hear what he just said he's
trying to lose weight
try it
try it
curry flavor just a little curry flavor
i notice they they only have like the
the tin cans or whatever that not the
tin cans the plastic cups right
in america they got the
little bag oh like the like the packet
ramen yeah no they have the they they
have it here
it's just everyone likes the
cup
wait what do you mean the cups are
everywhere everywhere oh sorry i mean no
the package [ __ ] you probably need to go
to like a supermarket yeah that's you
they sell them at the supermarket you
want the packet [ __ ] so you can eat it
at home it tastes better no it's no yeah
if you deck it
you get to attack it yourself oh what oh
[ __ ] no why don't just make a cup ramen
and then just like empty it out into a
plate that's not [ __ ] love the curry
dude that [ __ ] the curry wanted the
tomato does it my favorites yeah [ __ ]
love the dough
i think i think they all taste the same
right right
oh this is another all bread tastes the
same thing no no it's it's flavors taste
very different gone it's like there's a
curry there's a curry one that's really
good and then there's like a tomato one
that's yeah good there's a seafood one
that's really good for your taste buds
no no i'm i'm saying if like if you if
there's cup ramen in a cup and cup and
ramen in the packet that's the same
flavor they both taste the same oh i
thought you were saying the curry and
the tomato was tasting all right no i
was just i was just like because he was
talking about the packet because they
taste better they taste the same yeah
yeah yeah they taste yeah i'm just like
oh it's the best sauce the one with the
cup they've given you literally like the
perfect measurement of water to put in
yeah in a bowl i always overdo it under
to it you know
you gotta get good right now you gotta
that's that's that that just means you
haven't cooked enough ramen out of a
bowl you i know dolls i like the cup
noodles way more and also dude this
sounds like you're talking about easier
you don't want no no no no no
half of the experience is [ __ ]
holding it and just like [ __ ] going
no it's hot it brings your hand
put it in the bowl
what are you holding it while you're
pouring the hot water in
dude sometimes the heat goes through the
styrofoam and you're like
what are you what am
i mean i've never had that i don't know
how sensitive the nerves on your fingers
yeah yeah
i know because like with someone
depending on like the packet or flavor
of the ramen i i think it like requires
a different amount of water for like the
optimal taste yeah in my opinion you
know some some some sauces are a bit
thicker some sauces are a bit thicker
you like it was watery i like it like
thick man i like i like it concentrated
i like it watery
but that's the thing well like the cup
ramen right they have like a like a lion
on the inside which is like this is the
one so if you like yours water you just
pour a little more water than the line
yeah yeah yeah you poured a little bit
under yeah it's like perfectly measured
out for you yeah yeah so there's no like
you know gambling in a [ __ ] sound
like a cup ramen culture i just like i
like ramen
is [ __ ] awesome i mean it's good i
mean i i trash it is good i just prefer
the packaging it was invented by
americans dude like you're talking a
little bit about [ __ ] yeah oh cool yeah
it actually was actually it was invented
by the americans learned that the
cup noodle museum right museum yeah the
cup ramen museum
ramen museum and then you'll change your
mind i think someone went there before
i think people have gone there
yeah yeah
okay
people that have gone there before i
think
i think two of them are in this room
right now i think emily went to it i
think oh really i think there's one in
california that's why
oh really oh i didn't know that
so i guess we could just talk a bit more
about what you do yeah yeah yeah yeah i
met you guys at a
faku party yeah yeah yeah at anime expo
right here was that 20 or whenever the
last one was 2019.
why are you on what's your youtube
history why the [ __ ] are you on youtube
what's going on with that huh
oh
why am i on youtube yeah want me before
you on youtube oh yeah so oh yeah okay
okay
i get it here okay
so
so i was like i graduated college and
yeah i didn't want to be an industry
puppet yet
yeah what did you study in college uh i
went for uh 3d animation which i hate
okay i hate 3d animations 3d animation i
hate i hate 3d i want 3d animation
because obviously like career-wise it's
like safest yeah like if you go to art
college you're paying like
like 50 grand whatever every semester in
like you know getting yeah massively and
50 grand every semester
yeah odd college
and then they give you this lunch card
and they're like we put like fifteen
thousand dollars in here you have to
spend it all or it goes away so you have
to keep eating at the cafeteria to spend
all that money right right where else
the money is useless it's so stupid but
anyways
yeah so
after i graduated i was like jobless for
like
a year and a half two years i don't know
how long it was like probably the most
depressing parts of my life yeah it was
very depressing because
at first because i wanted to try to do
something myself like instead of like
being a paint bucket slave like on my
yeah yeah yeah yeah bucket paint bucket
i was like let me
try to do something
it was a massive struggle oh
i release a video
and then it would do poorly because
obviously when you're like one
subscriber andy you're like yeah yeah
like i can't do much right so then it
was just that i i just uh kept doing it
because i saw like uh people like like
uh dominic's james jaden
they were doing well at the time
uh story time animation was very that
was crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it is dying now like a little bit
obviously you think so
i think so yeah dying it's not dying
dying it's calmed down a lot it's calmed
down it's definitely not at the peak
yeah it used to be insane you can make
like any video be like i went to school
and i i sat down and i i saw a pencil
and i sharpened it and then you could
get like a million views on it yeah yeah
i remember like when it was at its peak
it was like every yeah no matter how
many times you refresh your home page
yeah yeah yeah there was there was a
different story time review
it worked i think james's like style was
like so simple
that everyone was like oh i could do
that too right right yeah that's what
happened
yeah because i remember like before like
they're like some of the biggest youtube
videos were like animation and then
youtube changed their algorithm to not
like to to to watch time on animation
yeah but people but people that the need
never went so you know there was you
know there was this huge need on and one
on the youtube audience for animation
but obviously it wasn't feasible to do
like the like the heavy new grounds kind
of short form animation anymore and then
that kind of evolved into story time
animations i think it's funny though
it's because they're supposed to be
simpler now but like now everyone has
like teams yeah yeah yeah yeah i wish i
had to i mean i should try to get one
but like
i have that like mental problem where
i'm i'm like i must do it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you'll you won't do it
correctly i gotta do it right and i hate
that i hate that yeah that's definitely
something you need to like let go of as
a youtuber so yeah i
i mean
i'm editing right i'm the same way and i
still like i still am heavily involved
in the editing process yeah because
yeah yeah yeah yeah because like to me
to me that is like my personality like i
can convey my personality through my
editing so i've had to learn what parts
can i give to someone else and not like
lose
like like lose this to be like a giggup
video you know that's that's that's
that's what i've had to like figure out
and that's the what the challenge is
because you can't continue doing
everything yourself you have to figure
out you know what makes a digest video a
dietis video and what can i outsource to
other people to help me with you know
because i'm sure you could get like you
know helpers to do say like coloring and
stuff like that
that's the hard part though is that when
it comes to animation it's expensive
because there's a lot of hours that yeah
yeah
and like in my head i'm like well if i'm
doing the writing to storyboarding the
animation the youtube thumbnail the
whatever like there's so many i'm like
doing everything right yeah and i'm like
if i give this to somebody else all
they're gonna do is just make it
polished and like it make it look better
right like let's say but i don't
technically save time that way though
there's there's like some things you can
do like this looks better let's say
you're writing right you could argue
that you have to write everything but
what's wrong with someone kind of
mimicking your style and then you're
going in and cleaning it up the more you
work with somebody i love that i just
need a fine line yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's all about writing that
it sucks because you need to find
someone but also and then you have to
pay them good you have to join them so
like you don't see a return you pay them
but it's but in the long run you'll
probably see it's an investment i do
want to do that because i get like i
love doing the videos yeah of course but
it it is a lot of work and i don't like
to say out loud that it's a lot of work
because yeah it's like
it's big
it's always a lot of work no the problem
is that there's artists who are doing
that but better or faster than you or
draw better than you yeah like you know
i'd say i'm pretty good but then picks
up artists are like
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but um
well take it like what what is like the
pros like your entire process into
making one of your videos then oh well
ah
okay um well first of all you gotta
think of like okay what what's like a
good enough video that won't be boring
yeah i i go for like the adhd kind of
like fast paced pace
right right um
but but the problem is like i i learned
that the hard way that like i've been
doing this so much i run out of jokes
because i'm like well i've done this
i've done this def no i've done that
another death note i've done that
i put so many deaf note like references
in there already i'm like oh well i need
to like
change my style or something
i'm running out of jokes man right
but yeah so i just start with the topic
and you
you half write it you bullet point yeah
and you storyboard storyboarding is the
longest because right that's basically
the whole video and then you just have
to clean it up right right so storyboard
oh yeah sorry you got to do the audio
because now you got to match the audio
with the storyboard yeah and then and i
hate the audio the most i hate audio the
most
why why do you hate audio
when it's like a home setup it's like
i don't know i have a
i have a hard time like because with
with animation every
sentence that you make is at least like
five to ten drawings yeah you're like
okay i gotta cut this down so i don't
have to like animate like an extra 30 40
50 60 drawings so you have to like cut
it like perfectly right right right
right
uh to save you some drawing time exactly
and um i don't know i just feel like the
expectations are like really high
for
any artist on youtube yeah because
there's always gonna be that guy in the
comments that's like well that's it
that's that was [ __ ] or something like
that yeah yeah yeah but
yeah all right
like i don't know there's always that
guy that's that's like what happened
your quality went down well well my
quality went down because i have to
release the video yeah you want it
faster right yeah yeah you take too long
they go where's the video
and then it kind of like it burns you up
i want to say i'm burnt out i would say
like i would make the video then i get
like burnt out for like a month yeah and
i come back but at least i like enjoy it
yeah i'll do it again i'll keep doing it
the problem was like i don't know this
uh animation or story time or whatever
they made this
like this
thing in the air which is like oh you
gotta do it monthly monthly right why
i'm like a standard i think that's
probably like an expectation of like
this seems like a reasonable amount of
time right
and like but also i probably said that's
like youtube's like
a good way to remind youtube that you
still exist and like yeah yeah yeah yeah
please recommend my video so things like
when when we me and emily do like stuff
with connor on his channel or whatever
yeah it's like hey we're still live
we're just
suffering from animating yeah
i tried it not to draw more than like
three frames i'm just like yeah yeah
because the most of it is the jokes and
the audio yeah yeah yeah um and then the
visuals are just like bonus yeah some
animators don't they don't they take
that too lightly and they animate too
much and then they
they're like oh man why'd i do this
right right so how long does it take
like to make one of your videos you
reckon like like without rushing it yeah
without rushing like hours well the
thing is like in a
in a mental you need to be oh sorry
sorry
i want to make sure it's like pointed
towards your mouth
yeah so um
you can move it around if uh how long
does it take to uh make one of your
videos like if you're not rushing all
right okay so like the thing is you need
to be in like the mental state like
because i think like you guys are i call
you guys um live-actioners
mate i'm not a live-actioner
a flesh flesh shooter you're a flush too
yeah you're whether you like it or not
that sounds like a toy that sydney just
boy you know [ __ ] like that's not
something
[Laughter]
but like for you guys like you you can
like set up everything and then be done
within like an hour two or three yeah
not necessarily all depends yeah well it
depends right yeah yeah right i'm not
saying like it it's easy i'm saying it's
like
um it's more streamlined yeah yeah yeah
like if you're not feeling it for the
day of like uh doing the camera yeah
like worst case scenario you're like
down by a day
yeah yeah yeah yeah or like you just put
up with it you're just like i'm still
gonna record even though like i feel
like [ __ ] yeah well we do that on trash
taste yeah yeah
is that today is it too late no no no no
no no no no i'm fine i mean there's some
days obviously where one of us is really
tired or what yeah like you know we're
not drinking or something yeah yeah like
oh we gotta do it yeah yeah exactly yeah
yeah i think it's just like you just
gotta turn on your brain if you if
you're working on like a uh
a film set or something or a tv show
yeah you don't get to be like sorry guys
uh i'm feeling a little tired yeah yeah
yeah it's like you just gotta like
because
now it's not just us right even even
then i would still be like all right
yeah yeah
yeah we have like a bunch of staff
coming in so it's like if one of us just
doesn't turn up or take care of
ourselves it's like it affects everyone
yeah you have like a staff too like we
have like responsibilities
that's how i feel when like maylene
brought us over to geeks plus i'm like
okay well now i i gotta work yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but it's it's it's like
it's a good motivator it's good
motivation yeah it's like it's like when
you go to a gym with a bro right and
you're supporting them because you don't
you don't want to let your bros down
right you know yeah because if you you
know you go gym
yeah yeah i'll skip the last set yeah
yeah yeah you're going to punish me yeah
yeah yeah
i feel that and i appreciate it like i'm
like oh this is why
there's three reasons why one uh
motivation yeah and then two food
we all eat food yeah yeah
that is true i can love food okay and
then i also love food yeah
wow what a hot take
the hardest take on trash tastes so far
i love i love food
well now there's like different
motivators now i have to pay for rent
i gotta pay bills
i find as a creator when you're around
other people who are very determined and
are making things and being very like
proactive and are really like pushing
their their
content to the limits it very much
influences me yeah absolutely yeah i
think we all stepped up our game from
from being in trash taste and we all
wanted to push each other yeah like
stuff like i've definitely learned so
much just by being on trash taste and
just being with the boys as well like
this year has been like i've been
outputting the most content i've ever
outputted in my entire career i missed
when you used to like not post like
[Laughter]
i was like my brother
that's how you know you can change man
that's how you know i can change i did
it i did it i did it man
chosen
i remember i remember these two would
post like so fast and i'm like i can't
keep up this is like years and years ago
yeah when he was working at the bbc i
could keep up with garnet because he
would like release like one video every
like three months and i'm like three
months three months
yeah once a year once every six months
or maybe it was like it was like a bunch
of years yeah yeah yeah it was like
dangerous like he's just like me
i'm proud of you son i'm proud of you
hey guys i'm still lively yeah yeah yeah
definitely yeah cause with the
animations because like i'd say like
i've learned a lot by being on trash
chase because it was like the process of
this is like so different from being uh
like a non-flesh tuber like what
[Laughter]
yeah because i was just i was just like
a disembodied voice you know like i had
never shared my face or anything but
like all of my content like you was like
very scripted you know like highly
edited and stuff like that so i would
have like you know aside from the
drawing i would have like a some a very
similar process i i i
i noticed that yeah yeah and like the
big difference between working on trash
taste and working with you know live
action videos is that there is like
there is like a clear
separation between okay work starts
camera is on you are working now cameras
stop recording
job's over or like videos yeah yeah yeah
yeah but like there is a clear
separation be like okay my work here is
done i can just relax whereas with
scripted videos and with like edited
videos you're just like oh i could maybe
do a little bit more there's too much
potential yeah yeah yeah yeah like you
got too much you waste too much time
exactly exactly there's there's no clear
separation about when you should start
and when the project is over yeah
because there's always like a little a
little bit you can do more there's like
things here my biggest problem with the
yeah the videos it's quality quantity
and stuff yeah if it's quantity i get
too bored because i'm not challenging
myself if it's quality i take too damn
long i'd be so scared to take one month
and just know that like it could not do
well i know i know you know i cry like
every time i i upload a video i [ __ ]
i'm like
i'm dead i'm like
i just i cry i don't actually cry but
i'm just like i'm sad for like two days
why and then but i pick myself up
even if it does well yep because like
when you first release it you're like
what if nobody watches it right right
and you you wonder that for like
whatever but first for some reason
animation it's like trinkling views it's
like yeah like with animation it's
definitely more like you know it picks
up really quickly over a long period of
time yeah long period of time where it's
like a lot of like flesh tubing videos
it's like
less tube videos not flesh tubing
that was weird
but with a lot of like flesh tube videos
like me and connor's like
yeah it's like usually it's like within
the first week or something it's like
majority of the views and then maybe
every now and then it'll like kind of
pick up you know in the long run some
videos just like don't stop getting
views yeah but i'd say like you know i'd
say i don't know about in your case but
like most videos it's like the first
week is like yeah yeah yeah for sure
yeah yeah occasionally you just get like
one video that just seems to like defy
it's like oh
yeah yeah is this so funny because like
sometimes like conor will be like oh
this video didn't perform well he gets
like sad i'm like bro you only took like
a week to make that [ __ ]
well sometimes i'll take like two months
to make one video i don't know there's
some videos that have taken me like
months and there's ones that take me
five minutes yeah yeah yeah it's like
the dichotomy is like shocking at times
yeah
he's not going to be like that with the
video he took five minutes yeah what we
can what we could share together is that
the [ __ ] youtube studios is
pure pain
why is it in the front just hide that
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i completely agree
it should not be front and center
like like yeah just like
they remove dislikes and then they keep
the [ __ ] one actual thing that is
like actual detrimental to my mental
health front and center everyone i don't
know a single person that likes that
feature like i i i'm fine with it if you
have to dig for it yeah yeah yeah
exactly
why is it in the very front page why is
it when i just want to see how my video
is doing that's the first thing i have
to see like i'm forced to see it you
know and it's like oh you're you're [ __ ]
and then
you're [ __ ] today oh yeah okay
it's just such because i guess if you
upload a video that doesn't do well for
a one whole month you got to look at it
yeah you get you get sad and you're like
oh man
yeah yeah yeah it's
scary i like kind of like intermittently
just like remove the app entirely from
my phone especially if it's like a video
that's like you know like a 9 out of 10
or something i was like i don't want to
[ __ ] look at this yeah all right so i
just like remove it from my phone until
my next video yeah yeah if it does well
then i see the fireworks i was like all
right installing that [ __ ] again baby
yeah you know it's a video that's not
gonna do well as well but you're like
well i like this video i'm gonna upload
it yeah no people aren't gonna watch it
yeah or i know that youtube's gonna like
kill it yeah yeah yeah yeah this episode
is sponsored by boxer guys it's time to
touch some grass wait what what's up
would you hate the saying the grass is
always greener on the other side right
of course of course of course well not
this time what's on the other side you
might be asking well it's boxing oh my
lord it was right here box is a monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
straight from japan to your door each
box who features a new theme providing a
gourmet journey through japan every
single month this month's boxu is in the
theme of midori moments do you guys know
what midori means joey midori is green
and japanese do you get it now guys
nihongo joseph well this is the ujimachi
waffle cookie it's got two thick and
crumbly waffle cookies in case in a
smooth and rich matcha infused cream
between their ridges how's that oh
that's really good actually what i would
personally recommend is to pair this
with use a green tea because it's kind
of got like the the sourness of the user
but like the mildness of the green tea
get all of these wonderful and delicious
matcha flavored treats with boku and use
our code trash taste 15 and the link in
the description below to save 15 off
your order um delicious
uh animators or whatever i don't know
what you call them i don't like being
called something because story time
people no because you call the story
time it's like the community is like
or like
i'm a be tuber and then you get attacked
by the youtuber community is like when
you have i think that's just like any
community
this community in general the word
community is always toxic no matter what
yeah i just like i've always just called
it i'm just like i'm an artist yeah i
just i'm just an artist i don't know
but like i've noticed like a lot of
story time animators are like yeah
they've
they they don't
they they don't post it anymore actually
like a lot of them yeah they're all
burnt out it's such a burnt they're
burning out kind of well they're like
kind of doing other stuff like twitch
and you know all that i mean i get it
right because switch is like it's like
feeding it if you're if you're only
every day you're facing a big boom right
and you're on a trend that's like
absolutely crushing it and then suddenly
you and all your peers are like making
half the money and yeah you have to put
it yeah
you put in like double the time yeah
yeah like what like half the money half
of you like triple the time and then
it's like and then it's like all right
well what do we what why am i doing this
yeah so like a lot of the story times
are trying to like pivot yeah yeah yeah
i'm trying to pivot a little bit just
just to have like
faster like feasible like content
yeah because i i think like especially
you know
with storytime youtubers because it
takes so much work
um and you it's impossible to like not
make not spend a month on this video and
pour your [ __ ] heart and soul into it
you know yeah like you have no life it
yeah yeah yeah three weeks of no lifeing
i would say yes and that's like a lot to
invest emotionally if your video is not
going to perform well
yeah yeah yeah i mean like uh you know
you put three weeks out of working you
get like a thousand bucks like that like
well that's why we we try to take like
any sponsor if we can like please right
right yeah yeah because i mean if you if
you did three works of three weeks worth
of work in a very specialized industry
yeah and they gave you a thousand bucks
for like doing like i'm gonna be honest
i would i would i would probably quit by
now if i didn't get sponsors i was like
it's like it's not worth it but i hate
when people are like oh because you
don't you don't you're not doing it for
the art it's like [ __ ] no yeah i'm
trying to pay rent like yeah yeah yeah
easy enough to say that when you live
with your parents right yeah
like
in the start it was yeah it was like
yeah i'm doing this because it's hard
because i yeah i love doing it and i i
still do it yeah yeah yeah yeah i do
enjoy doing it but the thing is i i
enjoy doing it but if i can't pay rent
with it i can't yeah yeah yeah yeah like
i gotta go and get a job and then i'll
upload once every night and it's not
even that nice
like it's not even that nowadays either
it's like you know you it's like i also
need to pay my [ __ ] editor i need to
pay people who help me in shoots you
know yeah it's not just me anymore yeah
it's it's annoying too because like for
some reason like uh live-actioners that
they get a they get flesh
flush tuber yeah they get a password
when they do sponsors and then when like
animators do it it's just like
really what happened to the passion
really really
not anymore it usually it used to i
think that used to be like everyone yeah
that used to be for everyone it's like
if your sponsor wasn't like directly
involved with your content yeah yeah
yeah like oh you're such a [ __ ]
seller like i remember
like i remember when patreon yeah i
remember when patreon first launched and
like anyone who got a patreon was just
like wow i can't believe you sold out my
god you think i'm going to [ __ ]
donate to you
stop e-begging you [ __ ] like
they called it e-begging and it was and
i was just like it's it's it's nice that
the mentality has completely changed
over time to now be like oh this video
has not got a sponsor yo you you you
playing rent okay bro you know like like
sponsors like completely normal now
um and now nowadays thank god
like a sponsored video there'd always be
that comment being like damn joey
getting that bread today yeah yeah yeah
yeah encouraging about it yeah yeah yeah
five years ago
nothing like that no no no no no no no
even five years it was like three years
ago yeah like couple years ago i was
like nothing like that was around so
it's like it's just so weird now that
it's almost like i don't know
congratulated in a sense or like i i
think it's just more becoming more
accepted that being a youtuber is a job
and uh not just a job but a career you
know and we'd require sponsors in order
to keep the show running and i think
people have now more accepted that
youtube is one of the main forms of
entertainment that a lot of people watch
it's like i think now the the the
majority of the understanding is that
a youtuber getting sponsored means that
there's going to be better quality [ __ ]
because i think because like it's gone
sometimes yeah sometimes you know like
you know i think they just want the
money yeah sometimes they just want the
money of course but like i think the
general understanding is like oh they're
going to use this money to like up their
quality or like their content in
whatever way right yeah
well like the first job of being a
youtuber is making it sustainable and
making it like making it so you can
support yourself and a lot of the times
you can't support yourself without a
patreon or without sponsors you know
there are some forms of content like
animators which have like which you guys
have a much harder time generating
revenue when you upload once a month
yeah well why didn't you why didn't any
of the i never really saw any of the
story time people getting patreons i
never really saw it much that's the
thing like most i guess animators for
most artists all right they hate
making money because it makes them feel
bad because like it's like oh i'm
selling it to the devil like my passion
and like i used to be like that right
yeah but then like lately i'm like
bro i can't i can't do this like passion
only takes you like so long man you're
like [ __ ] actually yeah yeah yeah she
thinks yeah yeah it's like we still
enjoy it yeah obviously of course yeah
we want it quite a long long time
passion doesn't pay the bills
it's just like it's just nice it's like
bro
but even like passion doesn't get you
through those hard days where you're
just like i don't want to work today man
but i gotta upload something like we had
to like draw a line yeah yeah sometimes
[Laughter]
i'm done
there's like even setting up the whole
tablet thing and drawing a line and
sometimes
i get it
[Music]
yeah
no it's like i get it because like
sometimes i'm just like i don't want to
watch anime today but i kind of got to
you know because like yeah yeah yeah
because i'm like i'm like
how can you complain about [ __ ]
watching anime or like reading manga
that sounds like an amazing job and i'm
just like most of it's [ __ ]
i do watch a lot of [ __ ] as well but
like how do you do it you have like a
technique you only want something
i have a technique he's watching he's
watching four at once yeah
it's actually i i actually like some
shows i've actually watched at times two
speed yeah that's that that has been
like the lifestyle well that's me was
youtube every video i watched two times
like
what every youtube video because i think
about it like if i think about it okay
40 minute long video two times speed
that's 20 minutes i saved 20 minutes
yeah but yeah but can you not like
because i i've done that before as well
just to like test it out like half the
videos i watched i don't understand what
the [ __ ] is happening it's like too fast
if you're doing enough your brain could
be like ah but like it's
for me it's like commodifying
entertainment you're like turning it
into like a speech okay it depends
talking this is like family guy speaking
okay no
it depends right it depends if i'm like
if if there's a video in which i am just
trying to get information out of this
video like a tutorial or maybe i'm like
watching you know phillyd and i'm just
like i just want to hear the news said
to me i just need to like consume
information i feel idea two-time speed
he talks at two times
one time so so you watch entertainment
and due time speed no no only if they're
talking mostly if the visuals are like
you know like animation or uh i don't
know yeah talking that's everything ever
yeah yeah that's mostly youtube they're
they're talking so much
netflix you're watching two times
no
yeah so why youtube and not netflix i
feel like youtube is like more like
background consumable kind of like
content and netflix is like i want to
sit down on my couch and watch something
yeah yeah you know what's like that kind
of like netflix styled content on
youtube at all like you don't watch like
i only watched youtube one two times
yeah oh you know like like i get it
because like video is like two times
slower
[Laughter]
that's the thing it's like when i when i
take off two times speed i go to normal
speed i'm like are you so slow i've i've
gotten to like why is it like a normal
human conversation i've
where sometimes you just like you play a
video and you forget which speed is that
you have to check it's like is this
normal speed or two oh it's one point
five times i've forgotten what like a
normal speaking place is right now
because like because everyone talks at a
different pace but like i like the same
tempo with like everyone i listen to i
guess
we'll end up like with like the wally
movie dude like we'll end up in the
what information am i leaving out
nothing i'm still listening to the whole
video
there are some videos that need to be
watched [ __ ] 1.5 and there are stuff
like that where it's not it's not just
tutorials sometimes people talk too slow
but like 99 of videos should just be
watched in the [ __ ] speed
i think it's about 50 50. yeah like to
me to me it's about 50 50. there are
some pieces of content yeah i'm not
saying i will watch all two times drama
videos where you just like hear about
like news with like other [ __ ]
creators or whatever that is not
something i need to watch over like one
time speed man like [ __ ] that and
tutorial videos are the only ones i can
think of and like if you're watching
like a documentary or something that's
like one time speed you know if it's
like heavily edited you know it's it's
one time speed if it's just like a guy
if it's like a guy in front of a camera
just like talking about a topic or
something i'm like i still don't watch
this i just don't watch that
you watch a lot more of those videos
than you think you do five or a 1.5 yeah
yeah yeah do you watch like asmr videos
at two times
1.25 i can kind of get a little bit
behind but like two is just too fast one
point
like to me like two is seven five four
two like i haven't gotten to like the
two times speed meta yeah i guess
people just look at the timestamp and
they're like i can go faster
that i i want to do this faster hey you
saved 20 minutes that's like
your is your objective
objective to just consume more like what
are you trying to achieve by giving i'm
not trying to consume more i'm just like
like if it's background noise what's the
problem with leaving at one time speed
well okay
music in the background it depends how
uh how in okay no no
i'm like if yeah you do the topic two
times speed you said you used to if i'm
not and i'll make it slow so i could
join the background you see you used to
watch trash taste before you uh felt
like it was parasocial
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my god
was [ __ ] brutal man i couldn't do it
did you watch trash tasting two times
speed
um i tried it i was like emily let's
watch it at 1.5 speed she's like no
no because like it's like to to me if
i'm watching it
yeah so to be fair like if i'm watching
at 1.5 speed i'm like paying attention
so i'm like i'm like very consciously
paying attention if it's in the
background it has to be like a one one
one time speed but like say it's to me
it's just like yeah you you are
consuming like you are consuming this
content and that's why i watch it 1.5 to
two times speed whatever but like there
is some content that is like it's
technically entertainment but the
entertainment is gathering and getting
the information that this person is like
portraying i guess i don't know it's
it's really weird right it's really
weird that's the funny part is if i am
alone though i will watch trash tasty
god damn it
guess what i save a two-hour long video
i save an hour
i guess i guess i guess it's better than
muda who edits this [ __ ] at 40. yeah
yeah just sitting there doing nothing
else watching channels no i'm listening
is it can you listen at two times speed
and still do something else that's like
[ __ ] i can't hear anything dude listen
listen you ever done that thing
where you when you read a whole book and
it flashes the words like really fast
like and you could read the whole book
what the [ __ ] you talking about you
never seen that if they if there's a
thing on an image or like whatever yeah
they could they say like oh you can read
this book really fast if you just flash
the words like
it's the same day like if your brain
isn't
your brain if you watch too much two
times speed
you you get used to it it's like you can
speed up the brain's processing
[Laughter]
just watching everything there's some
people out there that's like me come on
man no i'm sure there is
a lot that's that's why it's a feature
on youtube you know it wouldn't be a
feature of a lot of people when using it
you know
yeah but at the same time there must be
some people who can only watch videos at
.5 speed oh dude i'll point two five
speeds no no no that's that's yeah yeah
maybe they take a while to process yeah
maybe if you don't speak english
very well you know it's your second
language i mean some phillyd videos i
have to watch a point five speakers i'm
like you're talking too fast really
like figuratively yeah i'm like i wish i
could i think d is like one point seven
five one point seven it's like it's not
quite
that's not quite two he's talking about
brain aneurysm hearing this it sounds
like white noise after a while
oh my god i mean it's just it's just
like
you know how like when you've read manga
you can like pick pick like the pace
you're reading at right yeah so everyone
has a different pace right yeah
so the way i see it is that it's just
you're you're picking the pace in which
you like are able to get this like
information because like why is it that
why is it any different from like
speeding through a few pages versus some
people who really want to like look at
the artwork and you know appreciate
what's being drawn and some people are
just like all right
there we go you know that's that's how i
see it because it's the difference
between like the treadmill and the
exercise bike right the treadmill you
pick the speeds and then it like you've
got to try and keep up with it yeah
because the bike is like it's as fast as
you can make it go yeah right you're
what i mean that's a good analogy
it's not it's not the same action right
because you're reading and it's like
you're putting an effort to read this
thing so obviously you can push it but
if you're if the treadmill's going too
fast you can't keep up well you're not
reading a manga no no you have 20
seconds before
no but what i am saying is like if you
set it at a speed where you can keep up
then which reminds me yeah speaking of
pacing
a dude yeah a heated toilet of course
yeah yeah now the the bidet yeah oh god
it's [ __ ] amazing
but first
so emily emily pees longer than she
poops i swear to god i say this a lot
but actually that's true yeah and she's
like why you poop so long and it's
because
it's like the best time i love pooping i
agree i agree i love it as well what
made you just bring this up
oh because i heard poop and i heard
people
i didn't all say poop you said you said
i did not say food
on rewriting the clips i did not say
food
okay that was poop and then manga cause
i read my manga all in the toilet right
i only read manga on the toilet so then
when you said manga i thought a bathroom
and then you said
that's just something weird
he's like reading and he just wants to
[ __ ]
this is like that scene where like
sherlock is like picking like the
[ __ ] like words out of the air you
know
it's like pacing poop
manga
it looks like i can make this a tangent
because everybody takes their time on
the toilet or not yeah yeah yeah yeah i
get that and i love the toilet so i i do
too i agree he comes over to my house
right and he's like
oh um oh no which uh
which bidet thing do i press right and i
was like you press the one that like
says uh yeah has an arsenal yeah yeah
that's right and he's like oh i've been
pressing all of them
i'm like what do you mean you impressed
all of them
he's like and he's like oh i thought it
was like a course
yeah like of course like a bidet course
meal oh my what do you mean
he's like yeah because one of them's
like hard one of them's soft and then
one of them does like a different area
cleaning their ass cheeks i mean he's
pressing like the the
bidet and then pressing the ass cleaning
the vagina
yeah i didn't know that was a vagina one
i thought the picture looked like it
splashes your butt yeah yeah so i
thought it was like one is for the
inside and the one for is the soft
inside after you wipe once
and then the third one is cleaning your
ass cheeks in case you got poop all over
your eyes
oh violet all your shits no no i don't
do it anymore and now that connor told
me that it wasn't a
uh that's the reason why dad's on the
toilet because he's having a
three-quarter
three i've yeah heard diamonds mention a
course before ever about meals or
anything he's never been interested in
it but suddenly bidet courses day
courses and i'm like what did you get
we're like a tux today
it's like let me see the menu let me see
your menu oh we've got
like that's what you you saw three and
you're like i must be of course yes yeah
how would i know it's in germany on
screen here is the thing and there's one
the one that says oshiri is the one for
your butt yeah that's all you need to
press yeah and then stop obviously
obviously uh the other one is
stop that's the fourth course yeah
that's the end of it
which you might think because obviously
it's called bidets is actually just for
the woman's the ladies
it was just such a funny thing cause he
was just like i just was so wholesome
[Laughter]
so yeah like is the bidet one of your
favorite things about japan
oh and the bathroom the the uh the hot
tub i mean not the hot hot tub with the
tub
the top that becomes hot japanese
yeah
i remember emily said that you take a
bath every day yeah and now i'm like
watching netflix in it
dude it's the best it's the [ __ ] bad
and i get drinking
feeling like a king it's very nice it's
very bad because in america you don't
want to take a bath because you shower
in the same bath right so it gets nasty
and then you're sharing it yeah
i have to say
every single bath i've ever been in
someone's house in the u.s looks vile
yeah yeah yeah yeah like it looks
disgusting yeah yeah but that's because
they don't use it yeah it's just a place
to stay yeah and people people don't
wash their bathtubs much in the us right
no well i don't know it depends on how
mom does it depends if they're asian or
not
if one of your parents should have never
had that i've never had a friend be like
yeah i was just cleaning my bathtub i've
never like had that before my mom i
guess you're yeah asian mom is like did
you did your family take baths or
they're just cleaning it just for that
well yeah because it looks nasty but
yeah but there's still like scuffs that
you can't like remove ever yeah yeah and
you're like you're like looking at it
while you're showering you're like yeah
in the uk we had like a bath like
separate they had like no shower
anything oh really yeah did you clean
the balls no my mom did
oh no
people clean it every time
they hear a quick scrub right normally
yeah yeah my mom
used to at home used to like do a quick
scrub of it and then fill the bath i do
like every like two three weeks if i'm
feeling you know until i notice
something yeah yeah when i feel
something that i'm like all right you
put your fingers
yeah because you can put your finger
against it and it isn't like smooth yeah
yeah and then you gotta clean it sure
it's not anything bad you can't see
anything yeah yeah yeah well sometimes
you just gotta clean up the bathroom
period right because unfortunately you
just gunk up the best i don't know why
you'd ever want to yeah i agree like you
just can't it's amazing like i just you
know
the japanese showers are like wet oh
okay okay
you can put stuff on the floor in
america if you put something on the
floor you might damage your house yeah
yeah like all the all the like the mist
and stuff stays in the back yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so you don't have like the molds yeah
you say you don't have like the mold
build up sometimes yeah yeah that is
really good yeah
you can choose the temperature and the
level and it talks to you and the time
as well like you can like set that [ __ ]
yeah like you fill it up at 6am yeah i
just don't understand why we don't have
that in like the uk or the us like why
would we not enough people take bars i
guess
they would if you had a oh oh you're
getting up at 6 50 a.m you want a bath
set for that i'm saying i'm saying like
bidets why is that not normalized
worldwide it's catching up on america
it's it's coming yeah
but it's just like i think in america
just quick quick quick look like yeah
take your final shower get out but like
my baths aren't that long like you can
you know i i just like the fact that you
could stand on the the floor and be like
oh this is fine yeah
you step on the floor in the in america
you're like oh like everything's wet
yeah everything's wet yeah yeah yeah
it's not good
yeah cause like i remember like the
absolute state of like british toilets
right i remember i go to like one public
restroom and like you know this was just
like the day that i landed as well
and like this thing like forget not
having a bidet this didn't even have a
toilet seat i said [ __ ] you're not right
not even like huh is she i just i just
went in and i was like i was expecting
at least a toilet seat and they just
like oh my gosh oh my god this is the
most depressing sight i've ever seen oh
my god
basically it's like
an absolute state yeah absolutely yeah
it's so gross but like you told me
before that like because like because
you are so happy with the potatoes
because before you like wipe so hard
that you like
bleeding and [ __ ] i'm like what what
well in america i like to do this thing
i get made fun of i don't know why
but i do wet dry wet dry like i put my
toilet paper in in the
in the the sink to make it a little bit
wet so i'll get the wet to pick up the
poop and then dry to to clean it and i
go back to wet and i go back to dry
that's a lot you know that's a lot you
know what are you doing the course meal
yeah
you were doing that before yeah i would
like you you're like self-predating
bro i have the cleanest [ __ ] in
america
i like my [ __ ] clean i bet you thank
you very much
i mean like yeah i've
i've definitely never heard of that
that's [ __ ] sure
what is that how did you come up with
this yeah like didn't like did you just
figure that out yourself pixel poop and
then the dryer cleans it so wait how did
you like like you know damage wipes have
you ever used wet wipes i guess i guess
if you wipe too much on cheap toilet
paper or something yeah yeah and your
[ __ ] stinks it's not bleeding but it
stinks
that means
yeah it's amazing have you ever used wet
wipes on your arsenal if you're like
wetting the tires
i'm hearing that's bad for your ass yeah
why is it bad for your [ __ ]
i don't know i googled it
alcohol well no but there's weight wipes
that don't have alcohol yeah like you
got like the baby wipes right which is
literally just google i think
everything's bad so
oh happiness that's bad actually that's
true yeah oh you have depression
crippling depression you're sad forever
now i mean i'm sure i'm sure like baby
wipes right like wet baby wipes yeah
yeah yeah we'll be all right all right
yeah and that wasn't it seems more
effective than having to like having
like a
three-course could you reach the sink
from the toilet in your previous part
like oh yeah most of the time i was
gonna say because like are you are you
pretty well
right here so you just okay so i was
gonna say i was wondering if you're like
pre-wetting a bunch and then going
well sometimes when i go to a friend's
house i'm like oh dang there's sinks
like far away
so what do you do so what do you do i'm
pretty wet like a bunch
not a bunch not a bunch maybe like one
or two and then like what if you need
more
well if my [ __ ] is like
like almost clean but not completely
clean i'll like waddle over
and waddle back
your friends are never inviting you
thank god you don't do i have a clean
handle i don't know what to tell you say
bro give me bring me some
toilet paper
my ass stinks
so yeah like is this the first time
you've shown your face on camera is this
the face reveal
um for a long time
uh no you shoot your face right
when when you did the like eating
noodles thing oh yeah was that was that
in your mom's basement yeah it was my
mom's face okay yeah so that was like a
day before
not even a day like i was gonna i was
gonna have to take the plane within like
three hours all right and i'm like going
to ax that's when i met you guys oh okay
and i'm like well if i'm going to go i
need at least some people to like you
know recognize me i guess yeah yeah yeah
so i was like what can i do you need
people to recognize it
no clout no it just makes it more fun
yeah yeah yeah especially when you have
other creative friends that are like
yeah yeah you're that guy yeah yeah i
didn't know what you looked like when i
met you yeah me neither i just knew
about you yeah yeah because i was just
like
um
i would suggest anyone who's starting
youtube don't like hide your face like
just show it
yeah just show it right off the bat
because the expectation was like so high
all right
nothing i could have done would have
like been able to uh
deal with it so i was just like i'm just
gonna record a shitty ass video of me
eating ramen and i'm just gonna [ __ ]
upload it yeah you got like the hypercam
logo in the car yeah well i photoshopped
that myself
yeah well what i loved about that face
reveal video was that
the room was so dark and the quality was
so [ __ ] you couldn't see your face
you had to like squint being like he's
in there somewhere i think he's white i
think he's white i think he's white
yeah it's just like a i i guess that was
when i was like you know i was
presentable now i just got fatter and
i'm like [ __ ] i don't want to show my
face anymore all right
yeah exactly exactly i'm happy about
that and like what did you get like a
lot of people coming up to you at ax
during that time because i realized i
never really asked you about that i
decided them out it's like the thing is
it's like like i said like my hypercam
was like very hard to see
so sometimes it'd be like hey and then
you've already had like the [ __ ] you
know when they they're like have you
seen this man and it's always like one p
footage of like the crap yeah happening
that was like literally your face is
real it's funny because i did have blue
hair no okay i didn't pick up in the
yeah because you were wearing your hat
as well right yeah we you uploaded on
instagram like a picture yeah with me
and i was so drunk that day that when
you did that i looked at it and i was
like i don't remember this
because it was at the faku party and
like
i hadn't watched your face reveal video
at the time yeah because you know i was
obviously getting prepared for ax and
[ __ ] um
and then yeah i was just kind of like
hanging out and then i just hear like
hey joey
and you just like talked to connor yeah
yeah like talk to joey yeah and you like
ran over and i think i was like and you
know you came over he's like yeah what's
up man i was like who is this guy
but then i heard the voice and i was
like oh dude which reminds me that
that's sort of that's so crazy the voice
i don't
you know very iconic yeah yeah yeah i
didn't notice that answer
before i even did the face reveal on my
channel yeah i went to chipotle in maine
and i went up and i went to get my order
i was i was like scuffed i had a full
beard yeah i had like i was in my
pajamas yeah i was like could i get like
a
large burrito
steak right and the the lady the cashier
was well the burrito lady was like are
you a youtuber and i was like
no
[Laughter]
like because i was too embarrassed
yeah yeah yeah your way of talking is
very noticeable yeah i feel bad for like
corpse husband like he can't even go out
and be like is that corn yeah yeah yeah
that's all i'm saying like when you hide
your face like expectations too high it
it sucks a lot of poo-poo
no because like because like the first
time dice and i interacted he made an
animation for me like way back when you
had like 50 subs or something oh yeah i
was very desperate yeah
and i didn't know how to talk to
big creators yeah so i was like do i
talk to him like in a friendly way or do
i do like business or do i do like
whatever yeah and i was like asking my
dad i'm like how do i how do i interact
with like a big youtuber or whatever
because your dad really like it yeah
yeah
yeah he doesn't and he's just like oh so
i tried different things and i was like
this is [ __ ] cringe like the last
email i said was so cringy i really i
don't even remember oh good because you
didn't reply to it yeah and i'm like oh
i'm like
no because i remember when you made that
animation for me and you obviously you
know like put your narrative oh and it
got demonetized yeah got demonetized but
like
i remember like because you put your
narration into it as well right and like
uh your friend sen's narration was in
that as well yeah and you know and i was
like man this guy's voice is like
really unique like it's like i don't
know it was something about
the way
you speak i don't know how do you
describe that as a voice like it's
it's like it's
interesting inflections yeah it's
different words you know i don't have
enough descriptors to like be able to
describe someone's voice your tonal is
you know pretty standard but it's your
inflection yeah your voice like when you
talk it's like very like it go high like
this yeah i don't know just
don't do that
what i i remember
i didn't really
i mean i was okay with my voice usually
and then i had an ex-girlfriend that
said like my voice made me sound dumb
and i like took that to heart i was like
am i actually like do i sound dumb
then but later like on youtube like the
comments would be like i love your voice
on like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
okay
no no you're fine yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like it doesn't i don't know i
don't it's very it's a very unique
quality that i think you know you've
obviously used to your strengths yeah
obviously it's a very good thing
yeah yeah
when you hear it yeah exactly it's like
a media like yeah that's like especially
like neutral
it's only an advantage if you don't show
your face as well because like that
means your voice is so distinct yeah and
it helps set you apart from any other
person who doesn't show their face you
know showing her face is a little
sketchy because it's like will this
affect my
channel this affect how people see me
probably not though really i mean
because i i didn't really if you tend to
yes if you're doing something
concerning or something that people
think is widely like not accepted you
know you're doing like sexual things a
lot of people unfortunately they judge
you quite harshly yeah that's like v
tubers isn't it i guess a lot of them
just want it for the privacy though
right yeah yeah it's not there
yeah so that is shameful that yeah i use
anime i know i'm one of the worst
societies there's so many likes
sexualized like me i guess if you're
like if you're being you wouldn't be
that sexual if your face was maybe shown
i don't know yeah i mean the point is is
that there are a lot of reasons why
my immersion my immersion yeah
i feel like i've done this so long
though that like like [ __ ] it yeah i
mean like
i think like you mentioned youtubers but
i think just every every youtuber is
different they've cultivated a different
kind of audience as well so very much
toxic yeah yeah so it very much depends
on the kind of audience you cultivate
and you know a lot of youtubers have
shown their face yeah yeah yeah just
also don't want to show their face which
is like obviously like you that wine
that's totally fine yeah yeah because
it's the [ __ ] internet right and you
know especially nowadays privacy is a
[ __ ] massive thing on the internet
where i feel like a lot of people are
entitled to know what someone looks like
you know you know like obviously you
know they might go to a chapel and get
recognized by their voice but like
that's something they just have to like
figure out yeah like i feel because
that's their choice yeah like i said
like you mentioned corpse husband i feel
so sorry for corpses because there's
like [ __ ] stories no that's just like
[ __ ] that sounds like there's like
[ __ ] people like basically like
hiring private detectives like find out
what he looks like and [ __ ] right
i'm just like oh my god i can't imagine
like that chick who got a tattoo of the
waveform of him breathing into the mic
oh my god yeah yeah how do you even like
handle that kind of like go out
and like talk
yeah yeah yeah like he probably has to
just say like he just has to write on
notes
being like get a voice change
[Laughter]
have you like ever thought about
incorporating your your face into your
content more or less just just you want
to join the first game be more casual
about it i guess
faster but yeah i i'll think about i
definitely want to try different things
though was it animating um
drawing and stuff streaming or anything
like that i do want to do streaming yeah
i have a i made a v2 remodel myself yeah
cool um it was very hard to learn it was
it was like
was it 2d live
yeah yeah yeah live 2d yeah yeah i did
it all on the stream yeah i did it it
took me like i don't know like
a week or two
oh yeah it only took me long because i
was like taking my sweet time but yeah
yeah yeah and then i got another model
going on yeah
we'll play around with that and then i
mean
if i show myself on camera enough like
people get used to it and i'll be like
okay i could show my space yeah yeah
like every time i'm like doing stuff
with connor or you guys are you know i'm
on camera it's like that's what dice
looks like wow what the [ __ ]
yeah i will always get in those yeah
yeah i guess yeah i guess it'll just
take a bit of time for your audience to
like get used to it yeah but once they
once they're used to it i don't think
there'll be any problems at all yeah i
mean like even though i showed like my
face at the end of like every one of my
videos it was only like after i started
being on trash taste that people like oh
that's what he looks like and i'm just
like [ __ ] i've been showing my
face for years you know everyone just
clicked off before the ends and nobody
saw before so
yeah so like where do you think like the
future of like story time animators is
going to go now like what's what's
what's like the what's like the field
like right now because you said it was
like not as
not at its peak like it was because i
feel like well
for the most part is i it's a lot of kid
audience yeah um i tried to i've always
from the beginning try to
stray away from the the kid friendly
like i'll be like pg maybe pg-13 yeah i
have a rated r yeah um because i don't
want to establish myself as like oh this
is for kids and then they have their
moms angry at me and stuff yeah yeah
yeah yeah like a penis joke every now
and then um
no never because we could spend like a
month on a video and then have it
demonetized because you said [ __ ] once
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah so we don't swear
yeah
i'm too british for that um yeah i'm too
australian for that yeah yeah but you
can you can like kind of get away with
that if you're like oh this video only
took me like three days to film i can
try to i don't want to throw away just
so i caught yeah
it's not as bad as like a whole month
though you know
the risk the risk to reward is less you
know
i think my nude model video got like
demonetized but i was like fair enough i
drew like a dick and a butt
and another scarecrow
wait wait so you're you're afraid to say
[ __ ] because you get demonetized but
you're still slipping a penis joke
well
draw a dick
there's there's like cheats you can do
that's right oh it does
what's this what's the cheat would you
put a face on what's the hack you don't
make you don't make it too detailed
you don't have no brains
you could slip in like maybe one vein
well
2d animation or or just like story
timers or whatever yeah i think
if you have a team you'll maybe survive
and then most of them are will either
get burnt out or they're just like right
yeah i'm done yeah let me move on like
yeah
what do you think is like what do you
think it's like the path that most story
time animators take
because like the path of a lot of vanity
tubers is the thing yeah i think that's
the tough part um
for most part the honest only wants art
or like 2d yeah yeah yeah so
when they stray away from that path the
the audience loses interest so they're
like i'm not gonna i don't care like
whatever i mean but there's been a
couple of story time animators who have
still found success in like other
avenues right obviously maybe not as
like
massive as the peak
but you know like this like you know
there's a couple i can't name off names
specifically but like i think they're
trying different things i think i think
with youtube you always have to try
different things you have to of course
yeah i change everything it's uh i do
that sometimes and then like if i
straight too much i'm like okay i'll
just do one video to reset it and then
i'll start a straight again yeah yeah
yeah yeah like if it's like a full like
shift like completely away then that's
how you'll alienate your audience yeah
if it's like a gradual like fading yeah
i think that's the best way to do it
it's tricky though because since you
only release like a video like once or
twice or three times
yeah like you can only
slowly slay them like it would take too
long it would take like a year by the
time you're like done yeah slow
progression did you have like one video
that like blew up or did like crazy
numbers yeah so oh yeah so yeah when i
was in my basement dying and jobless and
my mom was like go get a job go get a
job and i was like
i'm trying i'm trying
uh
actually i was about to quit uh on on
the video
uh
which was called uh nude models actually
yeah nude models that one's on that one
that was the one that blew up i was
about to quit and i i told everybody my
family members and everybody because i
was feeling like [ __ ] i was depressed um
and everybody else was like if they
mentioned the word job near me i would
freak out
yeah
um but yeah basically uh
uh my friend posted a
uh on our slash video
my nude model video yeah and it got the
most upvotes oh and like it blew up so
then i went i made another video and
then it snowballed and it and then
that's how i'm here today oh okay
basically what was the thing that you
told your friends and family about like
if the video failed
what did you tell them oh well at the
time it was
it was always low views because i had
like what like 70 subs from so
he gave me like 700 subs but that's not
enough to like yeah yeah yeah
like if i don't get 100k views and
quitting
yeah basically what was the oh because
if you do it long enough you're like i
can't do this anymore like i
i have to get a real job because it's
already been like almost two years so
what were your views getting what kind
of numbers were you pulling in before
that and then that video oh like
a million two million three million
that's what the the it got
i think it's like
three million five million i don't
[ __ ] before that you were getting
like what like ten thousand thousand
oh i was getting like like a hundred wow
wow yeah so it went from like a hundred
100 views
i actually i went from like like 70 700
subscribers because joey and then i i
jumped up all the way straight to 400k
and then only people on twitter were
like or like
like like in my dms and i was like
scared because i'm like are they gonna
use me or they're gonna use me yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i closed myself off
because i'm like i'm like no no no yeah
stop stay away stay away because the uh
story time community where um
they it was built off collabing a lot
yeah yeah yeah yeah i felt like i only
want to collab when i like i really know
the post yeah no the person yeah yeah
yeah but like
but when you're starting off with
collabing right off the bat like you
know like that's what they want in their
mind yeah it puts me off i'm like
yeah cause like i've never had the
experience like just blowing up
overnight like hey i mean it's cool it's
awesome yeah yeah
yeah
every motion you see actually
a lot more cynical back then but now i'm
just i'm chilling yeah yeah
so you're like they're all going to
leave me they don't want to watch no
it's cynical as in i'm like are you
using me yeah
oh what other youtubers yeah yeah well i
felt bad though because i i i like
you know some people hit me up yeah yeah
i pushed him away i'm like oh but he's
like i learned later like a year or two
later i'm like you know like that's
pretty cool [ __ ] i ruined that yeah but
like i don't think i don't think it's
bad to be cautious because especially
like after you blow up overnight and
suddenly everyone's in your dms and like
well you guys weren't talking to me
before and now like everyone's up in my
dms yes you know and like that's that's
why i like i
i rarely ever
you know who like are on tv you know
like 30 seconds and then they're like
third cousin yeah yeah yeah it's like
hey yeah yeah yeah exactly it's sauce
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
and then like especially in the youtube
community there are definitely cool guys
and cool girls out there but there are
some but there are girls and guys
but there are definitely some that are
definitely just like not and
they are there for the class
like i have to meet them in person oh
yeah of course yeah i mean that helps an
awful lot yeah yeah i also found a lot
of the internet [ __ ] drops the
moment you meet somebody yeah yeah that
was you was a black butler you were in
the black butler at the time what was
your what you were black butlering
what to do with me you were like okay
that's when i first met you at the faku
what do you think about me online you
thought was an [ __ ] no i didn't i i
didn't even know who you were wow
[Music]
no emily introduced you to me uh yeah
emily you and emily were like friends
from the beginning and emily
he was a cool guy and like he and i was
like oh sweet and then when you talk to
me it's like sweet butter in my ears
dude
this is very nice
i see there's a story at the [ __ ]
party
okay i i was with a bunch of friends
yeah and i was like drunk yeah of course
the emily got too drunk and then she
ended up like throwing up like outside
yeah all my friends ditched me because i
went to the bathroom yeah and i came out
and i was like to poop
no no
i was peeing okay but i went out and
like i was like where where all my
friends go yeah and so then i was like i
was like i guess i'll force myself to
like mingle with the the anime tubers
which were you guys and that's when like
this drunk [ __ ] like comes over
yeah
yeah and then yeah that was my
experience i guess i got ditched so i
was like forced to like
just go around
yeah basically
the story
let me tell you about connor and then
you just didn't no conor was like my
drinking buddy i kept trying to get him
drunk i was like yeah right yeah i'm not
kind of junk like
i want to bite your drink yeah yeah yeah
yeah
it was fun
your friend's really nice as well yeah
they were
yeah they were awesome
[Laughter]
sorry i got like windows 98 products
i was like how do i compliment again
awesome
that's a positive connections are just
like fun vibes man like everyone's made
an effort to come out yeah yeah yeah i
was looking for a good time that's very
it's just like everyone's in their like
best mood hopefully
um yeah normally it's
super great i'm normally intoxicated
because
yeah yeah yeah yeah because i remember i
felt so bad because when you came here
and i was just like oh nice to finally
meet you and i was like oh we've met
before i was like oh we have
god karma at the at the party was just
here's a beer he's just like this
call him out
bro i was just like trying my best to
like look sober even though i was just
like i'm dying inside man
i think god had hit that you know at
that point where you're so drunk where
you just look sober
no no no no i thought he was sober too
i was at that point of drunkness where i
was just like existing and like
i'm just like what is going on right now
man his brain was just vibing
yeah i barely remember the [ __ ] party
that that yeah i'm going to be honest
um well yeah it's like [ __ ] it's good
to have you here like what's how we can
interact in the flesh again yeah yeah
yeah finally i have friends again yeah i
lost all my friends in uh
in the in the states yeah
so you like completely settled in now uh
like marvel
yeah the murray show where they're like
you are not the father yeah yeah yeah
yeah i wasn't i wasn't the one that that
cheated but i was in a group
right like one cheated on the others you
know and then there's a kid involved and
i had to like i had to leave the group i
was like oh this sucks because i've
known these guys for my whole life yeah
and all of a sudden this the murray show
hits me and i'm yeah
well [ __ ] i just lost all my friends
[ __ ] oh damn you you know like where
there's like a chance what kind of
stories
look i don't want to go into details
two
people just
did
not very
good things
i can't do this anymore i i i'm like i
told them i'm like i'm gonna have to cut
it off yeah yeah oh
i'm leaving this thing
so that kind of made my like my basement
dwelling even more intense right right
right okay okay that was like i don't
know like three years ago or something
right oh was that long ago three years
that was like before coving
you told me this story previously yeah
yeah but i thought it was recent i
thought it was right yeah i thought i
thought it was just like happened during
covid yeah and it just like made yeah it
just made your isolation even worse
during covert i didn't realize it was
like even just before covert well my
friends they're all like gamers like
back in the states so we never hung out
like ever oh
okay i do be like hey you want to go
with it yeah i could tell they kind of
don't want to they just rather
play the game yeah yeah which is fine
but you know this is but here it's like
now i'm like oh hang out yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm like all right let's go yeah
watch this shitty movie called the was
that [ __ ] movie doctor strange doctor
strange and the multiverse whatever
that movie was garbage oh my god
yeah yeah yeah yeah you were right
you're all right
yeah yeah
oh yeah you are you totally settled down
now in your new place then is you still
built are you still building furniture
like you were last time we have like one
or two
uh furnitures to build it never ends
honestly it never ends well i thought i
would move in like and then within a
week i'd be like working yeah but like i
moved in and i could do this
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you got to get your residence like you
had to go to the what was that residence
i call it like office office
what did you call it it was like
resident something oh the residence
certificate right yeah yeah or like
residence card resident office no
resident you got to tell them
the
the dmv like you gotta like yeah
when i wear my mask
people think i'm japanese so then
they'll like try to speak japanese to me
and i'm like
the next dusty yeah yeah
it is advantage but disadvantage at the
same time yeah it gets a lot easier like
ever since i moved i've only been to the
ward office once
i really have to go yeah it's like
setting up your life here takes a lot of
effort but you're like
luckily you're getting able to get a lot
of help and it's almost done and then
once it's set up it's like so easy it's
like freezing like very easy yeah yeah
damn thanks man shout out shout out to
you
geeks plus shout out to us being the
beta testers
yeah you just lying somewhere oh okay
yeah that definitely helps yeah yeah
what else do you have to do still do you
know are you what else do we have to do
yeah i need a computer chair mailing
[Laughter]
i wouldn't
it's my computer chair i needed my omega
chair
this instance
that's good though that you settled in
but like i i you know you're still on
that like
in a furniture building phase yeah i'm
i'm ready to work dude i'm feeling it
has the holiday phase ended because i
remember when i first moved to japan i'm
just like this just feels like a holiday
right now i'm not gonna lie like dude i
might do i really need to work i don't
know it's finally ended because yeah we
finally got like you know the sofa
before then we couldn't even like say
anywhere we'd have to lie on the floor
we we bought these uh what was those
those don'ts we don't yeah yeah we slept
on that for like three weeks or
something yeah
going for our bed like and then we had
no couch so when we get up there's like
nowhere to sit you can never rest
and then the only way to rest is your
wooden kitchen chair which hurts your
ass
you're the only person i think i've ever
seen who has built a pc worse than joey
really oh thank god thank you i i said
daddies was like i'm gonna build pc is
it hard and i'm like no no it should be
fine yeah i i've traveled before in the
past yeah yeah yeah yeah but you can do
it it's hard i've been there and so
thank you one day dinos texts me and
he's like connor sos literally sos
he's like i need help and i'm yeah why
what's wrong he's like oh the pc i think
i've broken it well it won't work right
i don't know what to do the processor i
go over to his house right first thing i
see is that like nothing is plugged in
correctly only like why are you scaring
me
they're wise it is it's daunting yeah
yeah i'm like where it plugs into where
like yeah i get it and so like i find
one problem okay let's fix this down and
as i fix it i find another problem
and then i'm like okay well let's fix it
and then as i'm gonna fix this i found
out like the motherboard isn't even
screwed in
oh it's just like sitting there it's
just like it's just floating it was four
screwed in so the motherboard typically
is like nine screws right yeah sized one
he'd only screwed in six and one one
half of the motherboard
you could flip it
and it was right
and it was like lifted up and i'm like
bro
you got like one month out of this pc
and so we have to take out the whole
thing even i know that you need to screw
up yeah
okay but it was like hanging up so i
thought it was like oh it's a different
type of case maybe like
maybe it's supposed to hang like that
but but then conor came in he put like a
little washer in it and then it
increased the size of the room yeah and
i was like oh
that's how you screw it yeah i just
couldn't believe it i was like this pc
it's you know it's going to last a tiny
cage
was it because you're watching was it
because you were watching every tutorial
time's too sweet
so he missed the part with his screen
it's like i guess it just screws in like
that right okay the problem with the
motion tutorials is that they're like i
have a different motherboard in a
different graphics card a different
because you were building it for emily
right so yeah and you want a pink case
in this case
right garbage it's probably the worst pc
case i've ever worked with but the
graphics card had like one millimeter of
clearance
like it like was it the only pink case
you could find in japan i think so oh
okay well is it pink pink anything
related it's always a miracle it fit
sorry it's a miracle it all fit yeah and
then there's like no room in the case
and he texted me he's like why are the
fans so loud
because there's no air
yeah yeah yeah it's like type of
ventilation you've got a 3080 in there
and like like one one bag of air
hey but it's fast
it works now i guess
but yeah i know that feel it's scary i
guess like you know since it is your
first time moving to a like basically a
completely different country like
is there like anything do you have like
a bucket list of things you want to do
still i'm sure you've like ticked off
all the food stuff right yeah for the
most part
and you know like combining [ __ ] like
yeah is there like anything you want to
like i want to go to a certain place or
i want to do this certain thing i
couldn't do in the u.s
or you're just like i've been the answer
now
hell yeah we're gonna take you to onsen
man
get over it in like 15 seconds yeah i've
seen each other's dig many times
let's just look at each other's dicks
yeah just get it out of the way just
like just slap it around you know yeah
just wait noodle fight for a little bit
you're like all right are we good
we're going to go to the bidet wash our
balls
it's
[Laughter]
i think you're really i mean you love
taking baths already right so like yeah
i [ __ ] love the onsen yeah it's just
like taking bath with your bros yeah in
a massive bath i'm down bro i'm down
it sucks though because like we can't
take you to like uh the one i took these
guys to yeah yeah
now
there's like another one somewhere else
was really far away oh really
in tokyo not out just outside of tokyo
okay okay i was going to ask do you have
any piece of advice for anyone who does
want to move abroad anything you've
learned on this thing yeah because
people because you you you like more
than anyone else i've met have just has
just jumped into the deep end yeah
without even like without even like
dipping your toes in at all well that's
just because of geek's plus right it's
just
no but like but i mean like you know i
i'm not gonna lie like i probably
wouldn't have the balls to just be like
yeah i'm just gonna move to this country
i've never been to yeah and just like
start living there like that takes a lot
i think you just have to be done you're
like i'm done like
i gotta go dumb
done done
just be done don't think
because i want something new
yeah i go yeah and also
it's japan yeah i mean like if you visit
it's still hard to get like the feel for
how it's actually actually live there
like visiting japan and living here is
like two completely different yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you wouldn't know that
either yeah
you'll never get that yeah
maybe that's a blessing i don't know
yeah yeah maybe it is maybe it is i
don't know i i enjoy it a lot yeah i i
have no regrets
i was worried when that like i was like
yeah you should come over and you're
like yeah let's do it i was like oh my
god what if he hates it yeah if he
doesn't i was i was really worried that
you were just gonna get like the biggest
culture shock of like your life which
because you've never experienced
anything like this before but it seems
like you're really having a good time
because for a lot of people it's like
it's so far off from what they're used
to yeah it's just that's what makes it
fun though right but yeah yeah but a lot
of people can't take that right a lot of
people are like no this is like too much
yeah this is like too much yeah yeah
because a lot i think there's a lot of
people that like what what
because because there's a lot of people
who are like yeah i love traveling but
then when they actually travel there you
know end up going to mcdonald's and they
like try and like seek comfort in a
different country in a different culture
i think
well having like
you know people i know yeah yeah oh yeah
immensely yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely
if you guys weren't here it'd just be
like it would be a struggle i'd be yeah
i'd like what do i do like
back in the basement then i guess
but in japan
very very fortunate yeah because like
even like small things like i remember
like i've met plenty of people who are
just like man the foods here are amazing
and they meet them like a month then
you're like
do people eat rice with every meal every
meal
i love that stuff i don't know i'll ever
get tired of the japanese food yeah when
i came here on vacation i got really
tired of japanese food really yeah when
i lived here i didn't i don't know why i
think maybe it's because while you're on
vacation you were seeking out japanese
food right because you were kind of in
that mentality of like well i don't get
the opportunity yeah yeah yeah it's food
even like the fried chicken didn't quite
have like the the quite the greasy i do
i do miss like
some american [ __ ] like yeah yeah yeah
yeah of course like that's that's gonna
happen but i think that's the cool thing
about like especially tokyo right is
that there's literally every type of
cuisine yeah out there right yeah this
is pretty crazy yeah yeah there's very
few cuisines that i'm just like i can't
get that here or like maybe i'm like
craving like a specific dish that i
can't get here but for the most part you
can get anything here in terms of like
good food and it's gonna be good service
and good service
but yeah anyway that's been uh today's
episode of trash taste i think yeah they
find you dialysis where do you want to
shout out oh oh youtube uh
yeah twitter
twitter uh
and then as underscore yeah yeah otl
he has a guy on the um
yeah yeah yeah
and then i think my twitch is uh ditus
otl also okay someone took dietis and
then on twitter someone took deitis yeah
and then on instagram is
underscore art i don't know why it's
different
just mix it up
at least you've got the digest you know
that's what's important yeah yeah thanks
so much for coming thank you so much but
hey look at all these patrons though
yeah i mean we're gonna be hanging out
like a lot more anyway like yeah yeah
we're gonna be doing stuff yeah yeah
yeah yeah when you're done with your
wedding
yeah when i'm coming like literally
literally you and emily come in i'm like
all right guys i'm i'm i'm off now i'm
off
yeah
but hey if you like to support the show
go to patreon patreon.com also follow us
on twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify
yeah yeah i hate your face yeah
no he missed out because it's time too
yeah yeah when i get to the patreon part
pause
[Laughter]
get out of here
all right see you guys next time bye
[Music]
you